Hello 大家好，歡迎回到無所適適的角落，我是赫套。
我是巴馬
今天我們要講的故事非常的動人。
赫套當時顯往稿子發給我之後，我在讀的過程當中好幾次眼睛都酸酸的。
當時看完我就給他發消息說這個故事真的太震撼了。
是，但是我們今天所講到的只是整個故事的冰山一角。
這個故事是發生在二戰期間，距離現在也已經有大幾十年了。
但其實這件事直到近十幾年才被這個世界被公眾知道。
在這之前整件事情都不允許被提起，就相當於被官方封殺了吧？
嗯，那當時發生了什麼？當權者為什麼要隱瞞這件事？
這一切還要從一份名單說起。
嗯，很多人都看過電影《新德勒》的名單。
對，這個電影講的是二戰期間納粹瘋狂的迫害屠殺猶太人嘛？
然後德國有一名商人，名字叫做新德勒。
他最開始的時候只是想發戰爭財。
但是他在目睹了慘無人道的大屠殺之後。
他的內心也發生了巨變，他就想保護這些猶太人。
於是他親近全部家產，開辦工廠來庇護猶太人。
而且還用花錢、惠魯、周旋納粹的各種手段。
救下了一千多名猶太工人，讓他們免於被送到集中營去。
嗯，我小時候看過這部電影，還是用我們家那個大腦袋電視看的呢？
這麼多年就到現在我都沒敢再看第二遍。
因為實在是太糾心了。
不過前段時間讀到了我們今天要講的這個故事。
讓我一下子就想起了這部電影。
同樣是發生在被納粹佔領時期的波蘭華沙。
我們今天要講的這份名單的主人，名字叫做伊聯納森德勒。
二戰期間納粹在波蘭華沙建立格都。
如果大家不熟悉二戰的背景，就可以先把格都理解成。
在城市裡面格出來的一座大監獄。
納粹佔領波蘭以後，把華沙裡面大量的猶太人。
趕進了這一片被牆圍起來的區域。
進去以後就不能出來了。
裡面的環境極其惡劣，食物不夠，藥品不夠，疾病蔓延。
伊聯納當時是一名社會工作者。
在當時的華沙，這份工作讓他接觸到了。
城市裡面最最脆弱的群體，就是猶太人。
於是他和他的同僚們把一個一個的猶太孩子。
從格都裡偷偷帶出來，給他們改名換身份。
藏進寄養家庭、孤兒院和修道院。
這還沒完，他知道如果這些孩子們只剩下假名字。
就算是活下來，也可能永遠都找不回自己的身份和倖存的家人。
於是他就和同事們一起把這些孩子們的真實姓名、假身份。
和藏身地點都寫下來，裝進了玻璃瓶裡，埋在了樹底下。
這份名單上一共有2500多名孩子的信息。
他從納粹掌管的格都裡偷偷救出來了這麼多孩子。
是的，那我們今天要講的這故事非常複雜。
設計的人名也很多，但是我會盡量做簡話。
大家也不用在意，就順著往下聽就行了。
那我們就開始今天的故事。
好
1943年10月20日凌晨3點。
波蘭華沙的一座公寓，響起了一陣砸門的聲音。
開門快開門，蓋世泰堡。
蓋世泰堡是因疫，指的是納粹德國的秘密特務警察。
最先聽到聲音的是一連大的媽媽。
她的媽媽身體不太好，所以總是睡不著。
當蓋世泰堡的軍學生出現在門口的時候，她媽媽是最先驚醒了。
於是她迅速的壓低嗓音，把一連娜叫了起來。
前一天晚上，一連娜的朋友楊卡來她家聚會。
夜深了，楊卡就直接在她家的客廳，支了個行軍床，流速。
一連娜聽到媽媽叫她，下時間就清醒了。
蓋世泰堡闖入家門的這個場景，她已經設想了無數次了。
於是一連娜穿著睡衣，跌跌撞撞地抓起了那份名單。
那是一團已經被揉皺了的卷煙紙。
然後按照她先前的演練，準備將名單扔到窗外的花園裏面。
結果她把木窗子剛拉起來，就發現花園裏面站著更多的蓋世泰堡。
他們正抬頭，恶狠狠地盯著一連娜。
怎麼辦怎麼辦，一連娜放下窗子，絕望地掃失了自己的家。
這使咱們生變得更大了，門板發出光浪光浪的聲音，搖搖欲墜。
在最後的時刻，一連娜和朋友楊卡對上了視線。
她迅速將名單扔到了楊卡手裏，並大聲說。
這是孩子們的名單，快藏起來，千萬不能讓蓋世泰堡拿到。
剛說完這句話，房門轟然倒塌。
與此同時，楊卡將這份名單塞進了自己的胸衣裏，夾在了夜窩下面。
一瞬間，蓋世泰堡就控制了房間裏的所有人。
他們一邊盤問每一個人，一邊搜查了整個房子，所有人都緊張急了。
如果被他們發現楊卡身上的名單，那幾千人都會因此喪命。
好在，蓋世泰堡此行的目的只有一連娜。
而一連娜也不停的解釋說，楊卡只是一個無辜的朋友。
前一天晚上過來喝酒的，什麼都不知道。
直到凌晨6點，折騰了半天的蓋世泰堡，讓一連娜穿好衣服。
他們準備帶她回舒查大街25號。
舒查大街，那是華沙蓋世泰堡的總部。
有人說，當時放眼整個戰士歐洲，也找不到比這裏更嚇人的地方了。
附近的人常常能聽到建築物裏傳來的慘叫聲。
每天中午和傍晚都分別有兩輛大車出入，專門負責運走屍體。
而這些車裏常常會發出烏夜聲。
有一些還沒厭氣的人也會被他們扔進車裏拉出去等死。
聽到蓋世泰堡這麼說，一瞬間一連娜又怕又喜。
她知道楊卡躲過了這一節，名單沒有暴露。
但自己卻即將會承受納粹最嚴苛的刑罰。
聽到命令的一連娜不敢停留，她迅速的穿上了衣服。
甚至連鞋都沒來得及穿，就被兩個人架著扔上了汽車。
上車之後押送她的德國士兵，經過了一夜的搜查，已經累得昏昏欲睡了。
一連娜在心裏迅速的盤算著。
她告訴自己，不管經歷怎麽樣的酷刑，必須堅口不言。
正著默著，一連娜將手插進了兜裏。
突然她摸到了一張卷煙紙，一連娜的心直接停了一半。
因為這個卷煙紙上寫著一個藏人的地址。
被藏在這裏的那位猶太人已經很久沒消息了。
一連娜原本想去探望一下，其實是去確認一下這個人是生是死。
但還沒來得及去，自己就被捕了。
這可怎麽辦啊？
就在此時，押送她的德國士兵扭動了一下身子。
緊接著又繼續睡了過去。
這些該是太保，很放鬆。
他們只當這是一次常規的逮捕。
畢竟一個身高一米五的年輕女人能做什麽大事啊？
所以大家都沒把一連娜放在心上。
他們不知道的是，他們此次逮捕的是波蘭地下抵抗組織中最重要的人物之一。
接下來，一連娜能從舒查大街逃脫嗎？那份名單會暴露嗎？
我們進入第一章，一連娜和同學們。
1910年，一連娜出生在華沙，她的爸爸是一名醫生。
一連娜兩歲那年得上了很嚴重的白日殼。
那個年代很多孩子都是因為這個病而腰折的。
那作為醫生的爸爸就決定要帶著小一連娜搬到鄉下去。
鄉下的空氣好，她的呼吸會更順暢，說不定能挺過這一節。
於是一連娜的爸爸選擇了自己的老家，奧特沃茨克。
奧特沃茨克這個地方一半人口都是猶太人。
而他們大多數都比較窮困，當地的波蘭人也和他們關係不太好。
她爸爸是一個醫生嘛，那回到老家之後就開了一個專門製肺結合的診所。
原本在當地，波蘭人開診所是不接待猶太人的。
但是一連娜的爸爸不這麼做，別管是猶太人還是波蘭人。
只要來找她，她就接診。
她不分什麼猶太病人和波蘭病人。
對，那很多猶太人沒錢看病，她也不在乎。
沒錢就說唄，就人要緊。
就這樣，作為波蘭人的一連娜，在爸爸的影響之下。
和當地的猶太小孩們玩的很好。
所以在小一連娜眼裏面，人和人之間是沒有什麼種族之分的。
那在她的玩伴裏有一個小男孩，名字叫做亞當。
兩個人是好朋友
亞當家是比較富裕的猶太家庭。
因此她也不需要擔心生計，也不需要幫家裏幹活。
兩個孩子經常就湊在一起，無憂無慮的玩耍。
時間就來到了1916年。
這一年呢，一連娜是6歲。
奧特沃斯克爆發了大規模的傷痕。
作為醫生的爸爸，也顧不上被感染的風險。
就奔波在各家各戶治病救人。
當時的隔離手段其實很差。
和病患近距離接觸，被感染是早晚的事。
那就這樣，在1916年年底，她爸爸就不幸染病去世了。
那這一年一連娜才6歲？
是的，她爸爸去世之後呢，診所不能開了，家裏就沒了收入。
於是當地的猶太社區就著手制定了援助計劃。
這些猶太人的孩子們當初沒錢治病的時候。
一連娜的爸爸二話不說，為他們免費診治。
所以大家都記得這份恩情。
那他們來到一連娜家裏，就找到了她的媽媽。
就表示，猶太社區願意資助一連娜，直到她長大完成學業。
不過一連娜的媽媽卸絕了大家的好意。
她就表示自己還很年輕，可以一個人拉扯孩子。
大家都很有人情味。
是啊，在這個地方由於一連娜一家的出現。
種族的界限好像就消失了。
那這之後，苦苦支撐了幾年。
媽媽最終是帶著一連娜來到了離華沙不遠的彼得庫夫市。
他們在那兒租了一間小公寓。
一連娜進入了當地的中學讀書。
那她在媽媽的呵護之下，就長成了一位陽光開朗活力私社的小姑娘。
除了懷念家鄉的田野之外。
一連娜還很想念兒時的玩伴們。
但來到了城市，她很快就適應了當地的環境。
認識了新的同學們。
到了高中時期，一連娜就談了一個男朋友。
他的名字可長了，我們就叫他小米。
二戰之前，波蘭是一個純粹的天主教國家。
所以社會氛圍非常保守。
高中一畢業，一連娜就和小米就見了家長，就相當於訂婚了。
這麼早
雙方家長都認為，兩個人門當戶對。
大學畢業後就應該順理成章的結婚。
那他們兩個人也是這麼認為的嗎？
那起碼這個時候是沒什麼意義的嘛？
這之後，一連娜和小米一起考進了華沙大學。
一連娜學習法律，小米則學習古代語言。
在大一的法律課上，一連娜見到了一個熟悉的身影。
亞當
他小時候的小夥伴。
對
很快的兩個人政治傾向相近的年輕人。
就很自然地一起參加各種活動。
他和亞當的感情也在日常的相處中逐漸升溫。
但是兩個人都不得不承擔來自家庭的責任。
所以誰也沒捅破這張窗戶紙。
1930年，亞當就和家人安排的一位友泰女孩結了婚。
第二年，一連娜也畢業了。
她和小米也結了婚。
但是婚後的一連娜過得並不快樂。
她和小米兩個人幾乎每天都要吵架。
有一天呢，一連娜突然下定決心。
她就對小米說
自己要去公讀社會福利與教育學碩士。
嗯，要去讀書了
小米對她這個決定就不知可否。
但其實她知道自己根本勸不住妻子。
1930年代的波蘭。
那是一個令人振奮的年代。
蘇聯已經被擊退，國家重獲自由。
大家都積極的參與到國家建設當中。
國內常常爆發社會抗議運動。
而社會福利專業是當時的新興專業。
那滿心熱誠的一連娜。
決定申請華沙大學的社會福利專業的研究生。
並且她也被成功錄取了。
當時的華沙大學就鼓勵這個專業的學生們。
積極參與社會實踐。
於是一連娜就報名了波蘭自由大學。
就是另外一個學校。
他們的教育系在當地贊助的一項社會實踐項目。
波蘭自由大學和華沙大學不一樣。
這兒的氣氛更加開放自由。
學生老師們都是左翼社會主義者。
那這個實習項目的組織者是海倫納博士。
是一位60多歲的老太太。
她是波蘭社會工作的開創者之一。
一生都致力於利用公共服務來改善社會。
是非常有魅力的這麼一個人。
一連娜在項目中就展示出了過人的能力。
她條理分明 沉住冷靜。
教授就很欣賞她
甚至海倫納博士還幫一連娜。
在社會救助委員會的母嬰部門找了一份工作。
專門救助城市裡面的未婚媽媽。
這份工作也給了一連娜穩定的收入。
在這個項目裡
一連娜又與亞當重逢了。
並且她也認識了很多和她一樣。
充滿進步思想的同學們。
大家彼此鼓勵互相信任。
但是到了1935年。
華沙大學校園裡面就流行起了一種隔離常矣制度。
就類似於我們知道的南非的種族隔離制度。
嗯 但他們這隔離的是猶太人。
是的 那就是在大學校園裡面。
猶太學生被要求和波蘭學生分開做。
比如在教室裡面
他們就會畫出一小塊座位。
猶太學生就只能坐在這些規定的座位上。
不能隨便亂做
那這已經是一種制度性的歧視了。
嗯 在這裡我們簡單的說一下。
當時波蘭的社會文化背景。
那波蘭呢在當時算是一個民族大熔爐吧？
在當時的波蘭國內。
本地人口是佔總人口的60%。
剩下的40%就是一些少數民族。
包括猶太人啊 烏克蘭人等等。
那當時呢波蘭的領導人又非常堅持民族主義。
就是他要建立一個同文化 同語言的國家。
簡單來說
他希望波蘭國內只有波蘭人。
他想把那些少數民族都趕出去。
那在這種政策下
猶太人就首當其衝。
前面你剛剛講波蘭它是天主教國家嗎。
而猶太人信奉的是猶太教。
並且猶太人他還有自己的語言。
就和波蘭人非常的不一樣。
當然政治傾向只是一個非常表面的因素。
他的背後還是宗教衝突還有經濟利益衝突。
是的 其實最主要的還是他們的宗教衝突。
僅僅從宗教立場上來看。
天主教就和猶太教本身就互相看不上嘛？
那不僅僅是波蘭
整個歐洲都存在著很嚴重的反猶主義思潮。
那具體的我們就不在節目裡面講了。
因為真的真的好複雜。
嗯
那話說回波蘭的反猶主義啊？
當時波蘭的國內有一群非常極端的反猶主義者。
他們甚至有自己的組織。
像黑幫一樣
是的
他們四處欺負猶太學生。
那自然經常和亞當坐在一起的伊聯娜。
也會遭到他們的毆打。
那相比於華沙大學波蘭自由大學則更加開放。
當有反猶主義者在校園裡面集結的時候。
老師學生們就會一起舉起消防水龍頭。
把他們給打出去
那奮勇當先的都是海倫納博士的學生們。
大部分也都是女孩子。
伊聯娜自然也是其中的一份子。
當時華沙大學的學生卡上面。
會標上每一個人的種族。
伊聯娜的名字後面就標了一個亞利安人。
伊聯娜就把自己的學生卡。
種族的這一欄亞利安人給滑掉了。
然後就經常在學校裡面大搖大擺的。
出示這張修改過的學生卡。
那代價就是
他因為這件事被華沙大學給停學了。
嗯
聽到這有的朋友可能會有點迷惑。
就是伊聯娜他讀的是華沙大學的碩士。
但是他是在波蘭自由大學參與的收賄時間項目。
對
他其實就是和自己的學校華沙大學有點氣場。
不合 政治傾向不合。
當時有很多非友泰的師生都非常反對這個隔離政策。
被停學了之後
伊聯娜沒辦法
他就繼續做著此前海倫納博士給他介紹的工作。
那這個時候他和丈夫小米也已經是分居狀態了。
但是兩個人都沒離婚。
因為天主教師禁止離婚的。
小米就去了別的城市工作。
伊聯娜則繼續留在華沙。
和同學們做著各種各樣的社會活動。
到了1938年
伊聯娜在一個教授的幫助之下復學。
並在第二年完成了學業。
在剛剛完成畢業達變後。
9月1號二戰就爆發了。
當時整個華沙在德軍。
一輪又一輪的轟炸之中。
就成為了一片廢墟。
城裡面沒有水也沒有電。
也沒有食物
街上橫漆樹疤的躺著很多屍體。
被炸死的馬匹
已經被飢餓的人群割的只剩下了骨頭架子。
此時在社會部門工作的伊聯娜。
就和自己的同事們一起。
打劍了十幾個大棚子。
專門給大家發周和。
9月27號華沙投降。
德軍佔領了波蘭
當消息傳到了伊聯娜所在的政府辦公室時。
所有人都一起抱頭痛哭。
面對德軍的長驅植入。
華沙很快就形成了有規模的地下。
抵抗組織
伊聯娜剛從戰場回來的亞當。
以及她曾經的同學們。
都是抵抗組織的成員。
當時波蘭男人
都被送到了戰俘營以及老改營給納粹幹活。
所以地下抵抗組織多數都是猶太人。
以及波蘭女性
伊聯娜的丈夫小米。
在抵抗戰役中就被服了。
二戰期間一直被關押在德國的戰俘營裡面。
那從這就能看出來。
猶太人在納粹的眼裡。
連利用價值都沒有。
像亞當這樣的猶太青壯年男性。
再讀博士生在他們眼裡面。
其實連人都算不上。
邪惡的納粹此時正在計劃著。
將波蘭作為全歐洲猶太人的聚集地。
在別處的猶太人還沒牽襲過來之前。
僅華沙本地就有超過10萬的猶太青年。
德國人佔領波蘭之後。
第一件人做的事就是文化滅絕。
所以整個波蘭的知識分子。
包括老師、醫生、教授、律師、作家。
天主教的神父、兄女。
所有和文化瞻編的人。
都遭到了蓋氏太保的追殺。
大學被迫關門
眾多的教授就聯合起來。
在波蘭成立了地下大學。
他們聚集在各處
一邊躲避蓋氏太保的搜查。
一邊組織大家學習閱讀。
那在這段時間裡呢？
大量的波蘭人被殺害。
而反觀猶太人
看起來處境反而沒有想像中的那麼糟。
嗯
在華沙被佔領的前一兩年裡面。
沒死10個人
其中差不多只有一名是猶太人。
就導致當時很多波蘭人會特地。
在袖子上帶上大衛之星的弊章。
來冒充猶太人
一次來躲避死亡
大衛之星弊章是納粹強迫猶太人帶的。
目的就是為了更好的識別猶太人。
然後之後呢有規模的迫害他們。
對
而此時猶太人不知道的是。
這種猶太人還安全的錯覺。
正是納粹精心設下的圈套。
嗯
所以納粹
他在佔領波蘭之後。
他是實行了兩種政策。
來分別對付波蘭人和猶太人。
對
對波蘭是他要進行文化滅絕。
而對猶太人不是上來就屠殺。
而是設計一個圈套。
讓他們以為自己暫時安全。
然後再用規模的迫害他們。
對
是這樣
那我們進入第二章。
隔絕之牆
這段時間
納粹悄無聲息地進行了邪惡計劃的第一步。
就是強制猶太人失業。
對他們進行經濟限制。
一臉納身邊的猶太同事們。
一下子都失去了工作。
貧困和饑餓
籠罩在了底層猶太人身上。
而有錢的猶太人啊？
他們的產業也被納粹殘食。
逐漸被德國人控制。
這個時候
一臉納在老師海倫娜博士的鼓勵之下。
就開始走訪身陷痛苦的猶太社區。
在社區裡
一臉納看到
一家六個孩子
一餐只能分食一小條肥魚罐頭。
這根本不夠吃啊？
在這樣的衝擊之下。
海倫娜博士和一臉納。
以及一些其他的社工。
大家就成立了一個地下抵抗網絡。
專門來幫扶猶太人。
整個組織有不同的小組組成。
小組之間互相獨立。
以保證彼此的安全。
而一臉納
就是其中的一名小組長。
他們最開始的工作。
主要是利用自己社工的權力。
來欺騙德軍
以此為猶太人
謀求一些福利
比如說
篡改一下文件
調配一下物資
本來社工的工作
就是收集數據統計資料嘛？
所以他們很容易偽造這些統計報表。
通過偽造各種各樣的文件。
就能套取到現金、食品。
和衣服等等這樣的物資。
嗯
那德軍不會查嗎
萬一他們去核實報表怎麼辦。
他們也不傻
當然會去核實信息的真假了。
於是一臉納他們
就會在編造這些假的家庭上面。
標上一個傳染病的標示。
比如說禍亂啊、傷寒啊？
這樣這些德軍就不敢去核實了。
很聰明啊？
預判了對手的預判。
很快時間就來到了1940年的秋天。
猶太人的處境變得越來越糟。
他們不能使用電話和火車。
不能在城市的公園裡面散步。
不能坐在長椅上
華沙城裡面到處都是反猶主義者。
德國人對猶太人的態度。
更是助長了這些人的氣焰。
他們會部分場合的隨意毆打猶太人。
而此時一同工作的。
一臉納和亞當
其實已經是戀愛關係了。
但是由於德國當局明令禁止。
所謂的跨種族戀愛。
所以經常和亞當一同走在街上的一臉納。
也常常處在危險當中。
這時候兩個人分別都是。
分居
但沒有辦理離婚手續的這麼一個階段。
那講到這我就先疊個假。
就是為什麼我經常提到。
一臉納和亞當的感情。
是因為亞當他是一個猶太人。
兩個人是兒時的夥伴。
並且一臉納受父母的影響。
他對猶太人的感情。
就不僅僅是不反猶這麼簡單。
這其中也有非常私人非常具體的感情。
那相對應的反猶主義在一臉納的心裡。
也不僅僅是一種錯誤的種族歧視。
或者是政治觀念
他更是一種真實傷害到自己愛人的暴力行為。
對
時間就來到了1940年的春天。
一場傷寒疫情
席卷了底層猶太社區。
4月德國人正式下令隔離疫區的指令。
就是封鎖猶太社區不能再隨便進出了。
這樣的指令很容易讓所有的人接受。
畢竟誰也不希望疫情傳播嗎。
而到了夏天
疫情已經得到了控制。
隔離區裡的人都盼望著什麼時候能迎來解封啊？
但是沒想到
他們等來的卻是一項更恐怖的規定。
10月份
華沙城的路邊貼滿了大大小小的告示。
街頭的廣播反覆播報。
德軍在華沙最破敗的街道中。
劃分出了73條街道。
這73條街道只佔華沙總街道的4%左右。
他們命令所有的猶太人都要搬進這裡。
而這裡原本的波蘭居民也要立即搬出來。
並且所有的動作必須要在兩周之內完成。
這個苗頭就不太對啊？
而對於這場覆蓋了25萬人的大遷徙。
德軍沒有任何輸到。
就任憑這些人互相爭奪資源。
一時間
整個華沙被痛苦籠罩。
街頭的每一個人都扛著厚重的行李。
連小孩都背著重重的包裹。
猶太人的情況更糟。
他們不被允許使用交通工具。
所以只能手提著行李箱在人群中穿梭。
伊連娜在自己的公寓裡。
看著樓下發生的一切。
真的沒辦法做到袖手旁觀。
因為她住的公寓
就在德軍劃分的街道旁邊。
而此時她的媽媽身體已經很不好了。
如果下一次自己的小家也受到波及。
那該怎麼辦
伊連娜她不敢再繼續往下想了。
還有亞當
亞當本來很富裕的家庭。
也在這麼多年的迫害當中歸於了貧困。
她不得不帶著母親和妻子。
搬進德國人為他們劃分的街道。
那此時的亞當和眾多猶太人一樣。
已經被多年來的反猶暴行反覆殘食。
精神和身體都已經在崩潰的邊緣打轉了。
伊連娜很想做點什麼。
於是她繼續利用自己的職務之變。
為猶太人謀求福利。
與此同時
她還到處收集應有官方標識的空白文件。
這些空白文件可以來幫猶太人。
偽造一個全新的亞利安人身份。
就相當於新的波蘭身份證。
那有了身份
就不需要搬進這個德軍劃分的猶太街道了嗎。
當然這樣做也有很大的風險。
而當時大多數的猶太人都認為。
就只是搬個家嘛？
也沒什麼大不了的。
而且住在都是猶太人的社區裡面是件好事。
最起碼不需要經常被反猶主義者騷擾了。
所以當時很多猶太人都還沒有意識到德軍真正的意圖。
是的
他們就沒有意識到搬進去之後會發生什麼。
就以為只是讓猶太人住在那。
還是可以自由行動呢？
是啊？
亞當也拒絕了伊連娜改造身份的這個提議。
因為此時亞當的精神已經邊臨崩潰了。
他完全沒有行動能力。
而且他必須待在他媽媽身邊。
因為亞當的父親早早就去世了。
所以他不能把年賣的媽媽給扔下。
他起初的一周
這片區域還是半開放的狀態。
很多人都能自由進出。
時間就來到了11月。
區域外的隔牆拔地而起。
藉著控制疫情蔓延的猶頭。
猶太人被禁止離開這裡。
同樣波蘭人也禁止進入。
華沙格都由此建立。
很快隨著各家的食物消耗殆盡。
格都內的物價飆升。
他們最終也只能接受德軍給他們的定量配給。
而格都裡
每人每天的配給只有184卡路里的食物。
這完全不夠吃
184卡路里是什麼概念呢？
大概相當於一小碗擺飯。
或者是兩到三根香蕉。
小朋友都不夠吃
更別說是大人了
是啊？
遵守規定就會被餓死。
於是走私飯應運而生。
為了更容易鑽過少俠。
他們通常是利用兒童進行走私。
但是德軍不會對兒童手軟。
他們不僅在高牆上插慢碎玻璃。
甚至會直接炒這些孩子們開箱射擊。
而對於那些走私的成年人。
德軍更是沒有任何顧忌的射殺。
在這樣的條件之下。
格都裡滿是飢餓與疾病。
仿佛人間煉獄
納粹害怕格都裡的疾病會傳染到外面。
因為軍營裡面已經有幾名德國士兵。
因為傳染兵而死亡了。
所以他們會特許一些波蘭衛生人員進入格都。
哦 有風險的活就讓波蘭人幹是吧？
嗯
那當時格都內有很多曾經和伊列納。
一同參與社會活動的友泰朋友。
亞當 艾瓦 阿拉等等。
他們進入格都後繼續做的社會工作。
比如說阿拉
他是猶太委員會任命的首席護士。
所以在嚴格執行囂禁的格都裡面。
他可以在一晚自由穿梭。
還有艾瓦
他是猶太孤兒救助組織的負責人。
負責為孤兒籌集藥品食物。
那這個圈子裡的每一個人。
分別都鏈接著
醫療 兒童救助地下宣傳和抵抗運動。
而這些社會工作者自己。
以及他們的孩子和家人的處境。
也都很差
但是他們還是不停的工作。
努力維持著整個地下抵抗網絡。
那身在牆外的伊列納。
通過研究生時期參加社會實踐的。
那個項目認識的一個老師。
就拿到了進入格都的通行證。
拿到通行證之後
他就不停的往返於格都內外。
一天甚至要來回走三四次。
每次進去
他都會在身上藏一些必要的物資。
比如說藥品 食物 錢。
甚至有一次
他自己偷偷帶了三支傷害疫苗。
這個傷害是有疫苗的呀？
是的
當時這個疫苗是相當珍貴的。
伊列納把疫苗藏進自己的胸衣裡面。
帶了進去
那按你之前所說的。
這個時候運送物資是不是有很大的風險呢？
是的
德軍明文規定了
如果抓到私下幫助猶太人的波瀾人。
直接槍斃
那通過檢查之後
他激動的就跑到了愛瓦工作的地方。
就是那個孤兒救助組織的負責人。
一進屋伊列納開心的把三支疫苗展示給愛瓦。
雖然只有三支
和這裡猶太孩子的數量比起來簡直就是悲水扯心。
但是他們還是為這份小小的勝利而感到無比的開心。
但隨之而來的問題就是。
這三支疫苗該給誰呢？
最後他們就決定
將兩支疫苗給兩個父母已經死去。
自己要獨自照顧年幼弟弟妹妹的孩子。
還有一支就給工作最勤奮經常幫忙照顧生病夥伴的孩子。
儘管愛瓦自己的孩子也沒有接種疫苗。
但他們還是把疫苗給了最需要的人。
這之後
德軍隊格都的監控越來越嚴格。
該市貸保發現了社會福利辦公室的人在暗度沉藏。
那被抓到的人會直接槍斃或者是送往集中營。
所以伊列納和其他社工走私活動。
這個風險越來越大。
他們不得不加強自己的偽裝。
伊列納從此化名為喬蘭塔。
繼續往格都里運送物資。
那與此同時這段時間。
華沙的街頭突然出現了很多小孩。
德軍館他們叫小乞丐。
這些孩子看起來都髒兮兮的。
頭髮上面都是獅子和跳藻。
而已經有德軍因為染病而死掉了嘛？
所以他們對防疫這件事很看重。
他們認為就是這些四處流浪的小乞丐。
他們就是傳播病毒的載體。
於是一場街頭兒童清茶活動開始了。
孩子們被一卡車一卡車的送到伊列納所帶的單位。
伊列納和族裡的女同事們就率先行動。
給孩子們剪頭髮除獅子。
用肥皂洗澡
最後檢查身體
他們做完這一切
就把孩子送到福利機構。
表面上這件事沒什麼問題。
但其實他們這個舉動非常危險。
為什麼
因為這些孩子當中。
有很多都是偷偷從隔督裡面溜出來的。
有的是從下水道鑽出來的。
有的是從牆縫裡擠出來的。
都是那些猶太小孩。
他們要么就是跑出來祈禱的。
要么就是走私物品想養活牆內的家人。
那因為猶太男孩出生的時候就會接受割禮。
所以這些孩子在洗澡的時候。
男生就會暴露猶太人的身份。
那一次給孩子洗澡的時候。
伊列納就發現
一共有34名
很明顯一看就是猶太孩子。
那正當他發愁該如何安置這些孩子的時候。
門外就傳來了德國軍靴的聲音。
蓋士太保
奉命來監督他們的清潔過程。
於是伊列納的同事雅嘉。
他就率先站了出來。
把站在外面馬上就要暴露的兩個小男生。
就給攬了過去
然後回頭低聲對伊列納說。
把他們倆送到我父母家去。
啊真的嗎
伊列納壓低聲音問他。
雅嘉慫了慫肩膀
意思就是說
還有其他的辦法嗎。
然後雅嘉轉身
就朝著蓋士太保的方向贏了過去。
拖延時間
最終這次搜查沒有猶太孩子暴露。
但有一個很棘手的問題擺在伊列納和雅嘉面前。
剩下的32名猶太孩子該怎麼辦呀？
他們希望這些孩子能有一個妥貼的去處。
如果把他們交給德國軍官。
那他們一定就會被立即射殺。
對呀？
那此時雅嘉想到了一個人。
他的名字叫做阿陽。
阿陽原先是華沙福利部門某個辦公室的高級主管。
他們全家都是社會工作者。
他爸爸和伊列納的老師。
就是咱們先前提到的那個海倫娜博士。
他們兩個的名氣差不多。
都是波蘭社會工作的先驅。
波蘭被佔領之後
阿陽也是參與了針對德軍的地下抵抗活動。
而且這個人很會運作。
一邊參與地下抵抗運動。
一邊還被德國人提拔為兒童保護處的處長。
他手下掌握著十多所不同的福利機構。
人脈很廣
兩面派
嗯
並且阿陽此前也知道。
伊列納他們在偽造證件暗度逞倉的事。
但是阿陽對這些事。
就是爭議之焉逼之焉。
持默許的態度
但是他不是為了給猶太人提供福利。
而是站在波蘭人的立場上反對納粹。
所以阿陽他其實是一個波蘭民族族裔者。
他反納粹的同時還討厭猶太人。
這兩個立場確實也不衝突。
對
當雅家提出這個提議的時候。
伊列納非常猶豫
一方面阿陽的職位確實是最適合安頓這些孩子的人。
但伊列納很擔心
阿陽的反猶立場會出賣這些猶太孩子們。
可能是之前波蘭國內的反猶暴行。
給伊列納留下了比較大的心理陰影吧？
可能吧？
就這樣
伊列納好幾周
伊列納都沒有鬆口。
他一直在猶豫
沒過多久時間就來到了1月份。
德國人先聯繫上了阿陽。
就勒令他立刻肅清華茶街頭的小喜蓋們。
如果幹不好
那我們德國人就要親自動手了。
阿陽知道
如果這件事落在了德國人手裡。
那些孩子恐怕就凶多吉少了。
於是在這樣的情況下。
他主動聯繫了伊列納和雅家。
伊列納他們也決定相信阿陽。
並且告訴了他實情。
就說我們這藏了很多的猶太小孩。
希望阿陽能幫忙想辦法。
你藏起來也好
還是讓收容機構偽造假身份也好。
阿陽非常猶豫
因為當時德軍的規定是。
波蘭人如果幫助猶太人是直接會被槍斃的。
那如果自己真的被槍斃。
自己負責的福利機構。
以及地下抵抗組織也會被一鍋端。
所以阿陽不想冒這個風險藏進猶太人。
但是他又沒辦法真的袖手旁觀。
畢竟把孩子們交給德國人。
他們一定會被立刻殺死。
猶豫不決之下
阿陽就撥通了一通電話。
接電話的是葛都里面。
一位名字叫做雅努什的老人。
他當初和海倫納博士一起。
給伊列納他們上過社會事務的課程。
他和阿陽的父親也是好朋友。
他也是一個大學老師。
這個時候他是在葛都內部。
負責猶太郭爾院的事務。
這個時候就是葛都的牆內外還可以通電話。
有幾條線路沒有被切斷。
兩邊有一些重要的情報。
會通過這幾條電話線進行傳遞。
葛都里面現在他還是存在社會機構的。
比如你講的郭爾院社會工作網絡什麼的。
他們內部的社區還是在運轉的。
是的
你是不是把葛都理解為集中營了。
有點那個意思我看見。
現在這個葛都不是我們知道的那種。
屠殺猶太人的集中營。
納粹只是把猶太人集中隔離在這個地方。
斷絕他們和外部的往來。
葛都里面的猶太人社區還是存在的。
亞當不就在那裡面工作嗎。
嗯好那你繼續
電話一接通
阿陽就開口說
雅努什叔叔
如果我送進去30幾名猶太孩子。
您的孤兒院能接收他們嗎。
那儘管當時內部孤兒院已經是捉金見軸了。
但雅努什還是硬了下來。
他要把孩子們送回去啊？
對
掛了電話之後呢？
他又撥打了一位德軍軍官的電話。
就說自己手裡有一些猶太孩子。
他懇求德國人能夠往開一面。
等到夜晚消盡的時候。
讓這些孩子順著圍牆偷偷溜回去。
那最終呢？
這個德國軍官是答應了。
夜晚
阿陽親自將這些孩子送到了牆邊的小洞。
一路上他們既要躲過那些。
在圍牆周圍晃蕩的反猶分子。
又要躲過少所裡面的德國士兵。
孩子們都很乖
一聲不吭
直到站在牆邊的時候。
隊伍裡的孩子們開始和阿陽一一微笑告別。
一個女孩小聲的對他說。
再見了阿陽先生
隨後他就鑽進了小洞。
進入到了格都裡
第二天啊？
得知孩子們被送回去的依臉納。
和阿陽爆發了激烈的爭吵。
他痛罵了阿陽一頓。
因為依臉納知道格都內部是什麼情況。
讓孩子們回去
那就等於回去送死啊？
是啊？
這些孩子本來就是為了求生。
才從格都裡面跑出來的。
嗯
但是對於阿陽來說。
他確實也沒有別的辦法。
他沒辦法把這些孩子們安全的留在牆外。
但是他也不想讓這些孩子們立刻被槍斃。
所以就只能把他們給送回去。
依臉納在罵完阿陽之後。
就立刻動身進入到了格都內部。
他來到了孤兒院
好在昨天夜裡
雅努時院長已經把孩子們都接到孤兒院裡面安置妥當了。
暫時沒有危險了
嗯
這件事給依臉納帶來了相當大的衝擊。
他無法在對格都裡的孩子們做事不管了。
這之後
他和同事們通過各種各樣的方法。
將幾千劑的疫苗送進了格都。
他們將藥品藏在有夾層的包裡面帶進去。
把鈔票塞進胸衣裡面帶進去。
總之是想方設法的往牆內運送物資。
那個時候格都裡面流傳著一句話。
想辦事找喬蘭塔
那是一個無所不能的女人。
嗯喬蘭塔就是依臉納的代號嗎。
對
依臉納一邊冒險送物資。
一邊心裡面在籌備著更大的計劃。
我們進入第三章
把孩子們帶出來
因為波蘭是天主教國家嘛？
那基本上小孩一出生。
如果是波蘭人就會直接去教堂裡面受洗。
依臉納就聯繫了一位外地的天主教神父。
神父負責的這個教堂呢？
當時被大火燒煤了。
但是他手裡面還留有一些空白的出生證明。
可以隨便往上填信息的。
對
因為教堂被燒毀了嘛？
那相應的其他文件也都被燒毀了。
所以這些出生證明就無從查證。
他還是想通過偽造身份來幫助猶太人討理格度。
嗯
這些證明就天上誰的名字就是誰的嘛？
那依臉納就坐著火車。
把這些出生證明拿了回來。
用來幫助想要逃離的猶太人。
當時依臉納就拿著這些空白文件。
找到了自己在格都里的猶太朋友們。
比如亞當啊？
阿拉
艾瓦等等
想讓他們偽造新身份。
然後逃出去
嗯
但是他們都拒絕了依臉納。
尤其是亞當的拒絕。
讓依臉納非常難過。
亞當當時是在格都內部的青年中心工作。
專門負責照顧生病的孩子和孤兒。
他是不願意撇下這些孩子們的。
那兩個人就這件事就爆發了很大的矛盾。
大吵了一架
依臉納他擔心亞當的安全。
但是亞當呢就認為自己和依臉納一樣。
也在為孩子們的生存而做戰鬥。
那當然
依臉納那些不願意離開格都的朋友們也是如此。
他們都在盡自己的努力。
維持著格都內部的秩序。
沒有人願意臨陣脫逃。
於是依臉納心中就做了一個決定。
那我們來把孩子們給帶走吧？
1942年的春天。
華沙格都之外
又出現了四千多個小孩流落街頭。
其中一大半都是猶太小孩。
有的是靠祈禱和偷竊生存的孤兒。
有的是猶太父母主動把他們從格都裡送出來的孩子。
那這些父母知道孩子留下來一定活不下去。
就讓他們通過強動或者是下水道逃出來。
那這些猶太家庭的成年人過不來。
他們就只能把孩子給送出來。
就算過來成年人也沒有辦法隱藏自己的身份呢？
對的
依臉納就觀察到了這個現象。
他就想
那些有父母的孩子們能把孩子送進下水道。
讓他們逃出來
那些沒父母的孤兒們怎麼辦呢？
就算是逃出來了孩子們該去哪呢？
畢竟被德軍發現肯定是死路一條。
於是
他和自己的同事艾爾卡。
兩人就想一起把格都內部的孤兒和患病的兒童先救出來。
孩子們就先從亞當任職的青年中心裡面開始挑選。
那為什麼我要說是挑選呢？
因為他們出來之後得隱藏猶太人的身份。
對
那首先呢？
他們得找會說波蘭語的小孩。
還得找外貌沒那麼像猶太人的小孩。
其次得會找會被送天主教經文的小孩。
因為當時德軍很喜歡用這種方式來抽查。
他們認為
誰不會被天主教經文誰就是猶太人。
最後呢？
還得找相對激定一點的。
面對德國人的詢問不露餡的。
當然挑選孩子也沒有什麼特別的規定。
他們一直都是盡自己所能能救一個算一個。
那孩子們出來之後去哪呢？
伊聯娜和艾爾卡就一起聯繫了一個格都之外的孤兒院。
叫做天主教兒童之家。
這個兒童之家的負責人名字叫小薇。
小薇是專門負責審核基養家庭材料的。
所以他知道哪些家庭願意收養小孩。
一開始艾爾卡不願意把小薇撤進來。
因為小薇他有家庭還有孩子。
他不希望小薇陷入危險當中。
但是也確實沒辦法。
於是艾爾卡還是找到了小薇。
就對他說
我這兒有幾個剛會走路的小孩。
還有幾個大點的孩子。
我們想給他們找一個安頓的地方。
那還沒等艾爾卡把話說完。
小薇眼睛一亮就回覆說。
沒問題的
你們把他們送到我們兒童之家就行了。
艾爾卡盯著小薇的眼睛深吸了一口氣。
就說
但是沒有文件
沒有文件
這四個字的意思就是。
其實這些孩子沒有身份證。
小薇立刻就明白了。
這些是有態孩子
於是他低頭
用鞋尖踢了踢地上的積蓄。
思考了一會
因為當時兒童之家已經被蓋世太保盯上了。
他們時常會過來檢查。
也會翻閱他們的文件。
而且他自己也不確定。
兒童之家內部有沒有蓋世太保的眼線。
但是思索了一會
小薇抬起頭
也深吸了一口氣
他什麼都沒問
就對艾爾卡說
行
這些孩子我來接
你送過來吧？
過幾天我們再商量具體的方案。
我得回去了
一邊說
小薇一邊開箱了兒童之家的方向。
他要先回去好好思考一下。
如何安置這些孩子。
沒過幾天
他們的行動就開始了。
營救孩子的路線非常多。
首先是
伊聯娜和其他幾位。
有衛生人員通行證的人。
會一起合作
他們會把孩子裝在救護車裡。
這些救護車裡裝的都是一些。
屍體和染病的人
當時德國人很害怕。
格都內部的傳染病嘛？
所以他們也不太檢查這些屍體。
還有的孩子是被一位年輕的建築工。
藏在工程卡車裡面偷運出來的。
當時格都要建格牆嘛？
所以有很多建築工人會出入格都。
他們有承包工程的通行證。
一般啊？
這名建築工
就會把剛剛服用了安定劑的嬰兒。
當然是格都的醫生給服用的安定劑。
他們就是為了不讓孩子發出聲音。
吃了藥的孩子們會沉沉睡去。
然後建築工會將小孩放在工具箱裡。
再把工具箱和磚塊亂放在一起。
裝在卡車上把這個孩子帶出來。
那還有一條路線是。
海倫娜教授和她的學生們幫忙聯繫的。
緊挨著格都的圍牆。
那個地方有一間法院。
法院的地下有通道。
能通向格都裡頭
他們不僅用這條通道來運送孩子。
有的時候還會運送一些物資。
給內部的猶太人
那挨著格都牆還有一間天主教堂。
也有地下通道
能夠通向格都
這條路也會用來運送孩子。
這座教堂裡面有兩個神父。
年輕的專門幫大家運送物資和孩子。
年老的神父
他還能弄到空白的出生證明。
那他們呢？
會教孩子們背誦天主教的經文。
好能讓他們更好的隱藏。
能掩好新身份的孩子。
才會離開教堂
被送到孤兒院
那除了這些呢？
還有很多其他的路線。
每天大家也都不太按計劃行事。
都是隨機而動
對這種戰士狀態
肯定一天一個樣嘛？
孩子們被運送出來之後。
艾爾卡一般就會撥通小微的電話。
說我今天把順路界的外套還回來行嗎。
對
今天這倆字就表示。
事情非常緊急
有的時候呢？
他們還會說外套的顏色。
也會說是外套還是襯衫。
那這些信息就是為了識別是什麼樣子的孩子。
好讓小微提前有準備。
運出來的這部分孩子。
如果是身體健康
看起來不是典型的猶太長相的。
一臉那就會給他們偽造假的出生證明。
然後他們就能以孤兒的身份。
進入兒童之家生活。
那對於看起來比較像猶太孩子的。
或者是患病需要特殊照顧的孩子。
在到達兒童之家的時候。
就會被裝進箱子裡面。
或者是裝進運送土豆的麻袋裡。
從後門給他們帶進去。
然後小微會照顧這些孩子。
先給他們洗澡吃飯治病。
最後他會為這些孩子們物色激養家庭。
那當時小微的兒子也一直住在兒童之家。
小家或專門幫媽媽照顧那些患病的猶太小孩。
直到他們找到激養家庭。
那遇到臨時無法安置的。
一臉那以及同事們。
會選擇把孩子先放在自己家裡面讚養。
哎
那他們找到的激養家庭。
也是他們這個組織的人嗎。
萬一某一個激養家庭。
是那種非常極端的反猶主義者怎麼辦。
對 你說的這個問題確實是。
所以小微和激養家庭在溝通的過程當中。
也是非常容易暴露的一環。
一開始大家都很擔心。
這些人會不會是反猶分子。
他們會不會給德國人告密。
但當這些家庭知道。
小微他們在努力的拯救。
格都內部的孩子的時候。
所有人都心然接納了這些孩子。
沒有疑惑人家拒絕。
太好了
就這樣越來越多的孩子。
被用各種各樣的方式送到兒童之家。
很快
莫名其妙多出來這麼多小孩。
該是太保開始懷疑了。
於是他們來到兒童之家。
檢查了所有的文件。
但是小微的工作做得非常細緻。
該是太保沒有發現任何問題。
那當小微站在走廊送他們離開的時候。
一名德國軍人突然。
就掏出了一把手槍。
抵在了小微的太陽穴上。
在場的工作人員都嚇得不敢動他。
他低頭威脅小微說。
一旦讓我發現你們在幫助猶太人。
那這座孤兒院裡面的所有人都會被觸覺。
小微聽完輕輕的點了點頭。
然後送走了他們
感覺這個局勢不太妙啊？
該是太保已經發現了不對勁。
接下來應該很容易暴露。
嗯
那這件事之後的沒幾天。
艾爾卡就接到了消息。
讓他去格都牆附近的下水道接一個小孩。
嗯
到了地方之後
他就聽到地下的井蓋就發出了那種。
指甲刮擦金屬的聲音。
於是他就趕快跑過去。
掀開了井蓋
朝裡面張望
井蓋掀開的一瞬間。
裡面一片黑暗
一股惡臭
巡了他眼淚直流
他背過頭去呼吸了兩口。
再一回頭
井口就出現了一個金髮藍眼睛。
滿眼驚恐的小女孩。
小女孩非常虛弱
甚至都沒有力氣自己爬出井口。
艾爾卡趕快用力把他給拎了出來。
然後輕聲問他說
你後面還有別人嗎。
小女孩太緊張了
就沒回答他
然後艾爾卡對著井口就問。
哈嘍
裡面有人嗎
確認了沒人之後
他還顧四周
然後告訴小女孩說。
別緊張放鬆一點
盡量微笑
因為微笑是最好的偽裝。
除了躲避路上的德國士兵之外。
他們還要躲開那些。
成天盤鋸在格都附近。
專門毆打猶太人的反猶人士。
這些人會專門挑選那些落單的。
滿臉驚恐的猶太小孩下手。
毆打他們來取樂
他們可真是自己家都被德軍佔領了。
還在那反別人
嗯
那這次計畫呢和往常一樣。
甚至還更容易一點。
因為這個小女孩看起來非常像一個波蘭人。
她還會說波蘭語
所以艾爾卡就計畫。
把這個孩子帶到兒童之家。
然後編一個故事
就說是在外面的一個樓梯間裡面撿到的波蘭小孩。
那按照流程
兒童之家會向德國警察進行報告。
說他們這找到了一個孤兒。
那過一段時間
他們就會將偽造的身份證件拿出來。
那這個孩子就能被留在兒童之家了嗎。
整個過程都是合法的。
所以他是不需要提前聯繫兒童之家的小威的。
但當艾爾卡帶著孩子來到兒童之家診所。
檢查身體的時候
突然出現了問題
接待他們的護士把小女孩給帶走了。
然後很粗魯的把艾爾卡帶到了另外一個房間。
那剛開始艾爾卡以為是有什麼手續要辦。
所以他就會坐在那等。
等了一會兒房間門大開了。
進來了兩名波蘭警察。
進來就要把艾爾卡給帶走。
啊？
原來是當天孤兒院的醫生和護士。
看到了這個皮包骨的小女孩。
根本沒懷疑她是猶太人。
而是斷定艾爾卡是一個虐待孩子的單身母親。
啊？
任憑艾爾卡怎麼解釋自己不是這個小孩的媽媽。
只是偶然在路上撿刀的。
警察都不理會
並且還對她惡言相向。
艾爾卡徹底蒙了
因為她非常擔心小女孩會經不住警察的詢問說漏了嘴。
萬一被這些人知道她是猶太小孩。
那這個小女孩就會被立刻處決啊？
當然艾爾卡自己
因為幫助猶太人也會被處決。
就這樣
她在警察局裡面做了一頁。
她就一直在想
該怎麼樣給伊聯娜報信呢？
得讓她想想辦法呀？
那這個時候
發現艾爾卡沒有暗示回到辦公室的伊聯娜。
也覺察到了不對勁。
於是她就找到了小威。
經過四處打聽就得知。
艾爾卡和小女孩被關進了警察局。
第二天伊聯娜冒充女孩的親生母親。
就去警局把這個小女孩給接走了。
那小威作為兒童之家的負責人。
就帶著兒童之家的醫生。
就是之前報警抓人的那個醫生。
幾個人就一起來到了警局。
一頓忽悠就說
哎 都是誤會啊？
這個好心人確實是撿的小孩。
我們報錯警了
而且我們也把小孩媽媽給找來了。
現在這小孩已經被接走了。
那波蘭警察也是一臉的懵。
但是他們也沒追究。
就這麼的所有人逃過了一劫。
還好還好
那這件事讓大家就很受後怕。
伊聯娜就認為
現在大家都不太安全了。
儘管這幾次沒人暴露。
但他們的舉動已經遭到了懷疑。
並且此時
他們這個轉運小孩的組織。
越來越多的人加入了進來。
格都牆外有25個人參與。
牆內也有20多個人參與。
那這麼多人
伊聯娜就必須保證所有人。
負責的部分要互相獨立。
他們相互之間不能有聯動。
為了保證大家的安全嗎。
是
這樣做一旦有人被抓。
其他人的行蹤不至於暴露。
同時呢？
被轉移的孩子們也越來越多。
那想要繼續把更多的孩子們。
帶出來送進兒童機構。
就必須得有更安全的方法。
更通暢的渠道才行。
於是他就想到了一個。
他曾經發誓災也不跟他合作了的人。
阿洋啊？
對
阿洋的職位
能讓這些孩子們
更容易的被福利機構接收。
那有別的福利機構能夠入局。
這樣風險也能夠分散一點。
畢竟阿洋就是管這些福利機構的嘛？
只要他在文件上簽個字就行。
於是伊聯娜和亞家找到了阿洋。
把整件事合盤脫出。
最終阿洋同意幫忙。
他不會參與其他的工作。
他只做一件事
就是打通關係網
各個機構包括教堂。
兒童之家各個孤兒院。
就向他們輸送小孩。
當時伊聯娜他們
如果帶出來一個
特徵很明顯的猶太小孩。
就會通知阿洋
這個時候阿洋就會在相應的。
傳輸文件上簽字
他的這個簽名就算是一種暗號。
意思就是
這個小孩需要得到特殊關照。
那在阿洋的幫助之下。
很多猶太小孩被安全的送到了各個機構。
在大家忙著轉移孩子的同時。
華沙成交的一項工程。
正在迅速的推進
我們進入第四章
集中營
時間來到了1942年6月中旬。
在華沙城外東北方向。
臭名昭著的
特雷布林卡滅絕營建造完畢。
整個滅絕營非常緊湊。
只有一個被偽裝成火車站的接待區。
還有一個獨棄式區域。
還有一個小型的勞動營。
以及一個行政辦公區。
華沙格都
針對猶太人的驅逐開始了。
滅絕營建好之後
格都內每天都廣播著這麼一句話。
猶太人們注意了
你們現在呆的地方是一座中轉營。
現在我們會坐火車去勞動營。
為了防止疾病的傳播。
你們必須立刻交出衣物。
以及包裹一邊消毒。
黃金、白銀、外幣以及珠寶。
需要交予財務處保管。
換取收據
日後憑此收據可以領回這些物品。
所有抵達者
需在第一時間前往浴室消毒。
就是在騙他們
對呀？
那一部分猶太人知道這意味著什麼。
而大部分的猶太人都被蒙在了鼓裡。
不願意相信
驅逐開始的時候
我們剛剛提到的阿拉還記得嗎。
就是那個格都裡面的護士。
他肯定知道德軍讓他們去的。
應該不是什麼老動營吧？
對的
他和一位猶太委員會辦公室的男職員。
名字叫老娜
兩個人就一起跑到了猶太人裝車點。
建了一個臨時醫療站。
那格都裡的猶太人都會被趕到這個裝車點上火車。
然後就會被運送到特雷布丁卡密絕營。
那他們建的這個醫療站是沒有經過德國人批准的。
其實這個老娜也不是什麼醫生。
原本他只是負責一些文書的工作。
大驅逐開始的第一時間。
老娜就和阿拉來到了這。
支起了一個棚子
自己假裝是醫生
那阿拉是護士嗎
就扮演他的下屬
他們就給德國人製造了一種印象。
就好像是在幫他們管理隊伍一樣。
當時的德國人也並不在乎這倆人是幹嘛的。
只要願意幫他們維持秩序就可以。
畢竟這些德國士兵的任務。
就是將猶太人一批一批有序的送上火車。
在阿拉和老娜假裝幫忙的過程中。
他們就會用醫生的身份和德國人交流。
就說
這個人生病了不能坐車。
那個人太虛弱了也不能坐車。
那個小孩太小了也不能坐車。
這些不適合坐車的人。
我們得先救助他們。
等他們身體好了再坐車過去吧？
那畢竟德國人表面上說的是。
要帶猶太人去勞動營參加勞動嗎。
所以按理來說身體不好的確實不能去。
於是德國士兵就點頭同意了。
而且他們也確實不在乎是不是有被落下的人。
他們只想維持秩序。
儘快把火車給裝滿。
那他們倆想出的這個辦法。
最一開始是想要先救身體虛弱的人。
和地下組織的抵抗成員。
但最後整件事情就發展成了。
能救誰救誰得著誰救誰。
那面對大人
阿拉會直接合盤脫出。
讓被救的人直接裝病。
那面對小嬰兒
阿拉會直接注射一針鎮定劑。
然後把小孩偷偷抱走。
伊聯娜呢？
她一邊做著轉運孩子的工作。
一邊會來到這幫忙。
短短的幾週時間
阿拉和老娜在德軍的眼皮的底下。
救出來了兩三百人。
那其中的一部分孩子。
也被伊聯娜他們轉移出了格獨。
而更多的人被火車拉走。
每個人都無能為力。
8月6日一早
德國人來到了格獨內部的孤兒院。
就是先前阿陽把32名孩子送進來的那個孤兒院。
當時孤兒院裡面住著200多名有太兒童。
德軍就下令要清空這。
要把這些孩子都送上火車。
往常伊聯娜都是下午進入格獨幫忙。
而這天她來得早
剛一進來
就聽到大家在那兒議論。
孤兒院要被清空的事。
她就趕忙往孤兒院那邊跑。
剛跑到一個街區的拐角。
她就見到雅努石院長。
正帶著孩子們往裝車店那邊走。
孤兒院在格獨的南邊。
這個裝車店在北邊。
孩子們要走上兩三個小時才能到達那。
一路上這些孩子們就頂著酷鼠唱著歌往前走。
看到這一幕的伊聯娜知道。
雅努石院長並沒有告訴孩子們即將要去做什麼。
其實當天德軍來到孤兒院之後。
就讓所有的小孩15分鐘之內。
跟他們一起動身前往裝車店。
而德軍並沒有要求雅努石和孩子們一起去。
這個雅努石聽後就非常氣憤。
她大聲質問德國人說。
哪個老師會在這個時候丟下孩子。
德國人聽後就鋪齒一下笑了出來。
然後就回答說
那你想來就來吧？
在裝車廣場
德國人用鞭子和槍托驅趕著人群。
一些猶太警察和德國人一起。
居高臨下的腐蝕著孩子們的頭頂。
對他們發號適令
直到登車的最後一刻。
助手在裝車點的阿拉和老娜。
才見到這些孩子們。
老娜看著雅努石院長。
幾乎是失控的懇求院長和自己。
再去做最後的努力。
看看德國人能不能延緩上車的日期。
雅努石院長搖了搖頭。
對老娜說
我不能離開孩子們。
只要我一走
他們就會立刻把孩子們送上火車。
而我不能讓孩子們獨自登上列車。
我必須陪在他們身邊才行。
最後
雅努石院長和一位名字叫做。
斯特凡尼亞的女老師。
和孩子們一起登上了列車。
伊臉娜、阿拉、老娜。
當時所有的人都被這一幕給震驚到了。
所有人都目送著孩子們。
他們看著車門被鐵絲一圈一圈的封住。
最後火車開動
孩子們徹底消失了。
當天伊臉娜完全崩潰了。
晚上她撐著最後一口力氣回到了家。
剛一進屋就攤倒在地。
媽媽被伊臉娜的樣子給嚇壞了。
最後甚至專門教了醫生。
給伊臉娜注射了一針強效鎮定劑。
她才昏睡過去
這個衝擊真的太大了。
那第二天醒來的伊臉娜。
就意識到了一個問題。
無論你擔任什麼樣子的角色。
任何人在納粹的政策之下都是無法倖免的。
亞當、阿拉他們
到現在還沒有被送上火車是因為。
德國人需要他們來幫忙維持秩序。
但隨著格度內部的猶太人越來越少。
尤其是亞當工作的青年中心裡面的孩子們越來越少。
亞當也變得很危險。
於是伊臉娜又找到了一批假的身份證件。
帶給了阿拉、亞當和一些其他的猶太朋友們。
那當時阿拉的女兒已經討出了格度。
她的丈夫在格度外的游擊堆裡面抗戰。
伊臉娜就找到了阿拉。
勸說她儘快離開
並承諾自己會找到安全屋讓她過度。
讓她和女兒能團聚。
但是阿拉給拒絕了。
她放不下這個臨時醫療點。
對 她想留下繼續救人。
那最後呢？
阿拉主婦伊臉娜幫自己照顧好女兒。
然後把伊臉娜留給自己的空身份證件。
給了另外一個猶太女人。
她自己則繼續留在格度裡面救人。
那亞當這邊呢？
她照顧的孩子們都被帶走了。
她終於同意逃亡了。
前提是得帶上自己的媽媽。
伊臉娜同意了
她先將亞當的媽媽給接了出去。
對於猶太女人來說。
只要有全新的證件。
並且願意扮演波蘭女性。
那活下去的機會就很大。
但是猶太男性不一樣。
因為他們的外表更容易被辯認出來。
並且猶太男人出生的時候就會行隔離。
如果真的被德國人抓住。
就很容易確定身份。
為了藏匿亞當
伊臉娜就跑去找到了自己的一個老同學。
這個同學的家是猶太小孩的一個臨時接應點。
伊臉娜祈求同學
能夠暫時讓亞當住一下。
嗯
但是藏小孩和藏一個成年男人。
性質有點不太一樣。
難度也不一樣啊？
嗯
這就相當於讓這個同學的全家跟著一起冒險啊？
最終這個同學看在伊臉娜的情分上就同意了。
讓亞當住進自己家。
安頓好亞當之後
伊臉娜又加緊了轉移孩子的動作。
時間來到了8月份。
伊臉娜他們開始說服一些。
不願意送走孩子們的猶太家庭。
先前他們是優先轉移青年中心中的孤兒和幻變的孩子。
對
以及一些主動找到伊臉娜把孩子交給她的人。
那對於這些不太願意把孩子送走的家庭。
他們其實最大的顧慮是宗教信仰的問題。
那半遠波蘭人就意味著得接受天主教的受洗。
而受洗這件事
無論是對於猶太人還是基督徒來說。
都是有象征意義的。
所以那些猶太人認為。
孩子們需要的是證件和安全的地點。
為什麼非得讓他們接受宗教的洗禮儀式呢？
對
那現在伊臉娜的任務就是要說服這些家長。
讓他們把孩子交給自己。
所以她和同事們對這樣的猶太家長就承諾。
那些住在天主教機構裡面的孩子們。
必須要融入天主教生活。
但是我們可以保證的是。
戰爭結束後
孩子們可以自由選擇是否回歸猶太教。
雖然這些猶太父母還是非常介意。
但是也沒辦法
從這個時候伊臉娜就開始意識到。
這些孩子們被送出來之後。
就得扮演一個完全不屬於自己的新角色。
甚至還會顛覆自己原本的信仰。
而戰爭結束之後
這些孩子該怎麼樣去找回自己的過去呢？
如果幸運的話
他的家人還在
他們又要怎麼樣去尋找到自己的家人呢？
伊臉娜心裡就開始盤算。
自己或許應該製作一份。
能夠記錄所有孩子信息的名單。
那想要記錄名單的另外一個原因還有錢。
每一個被轉移的孩子都需要用錢來安置。
孩子們要吃飯 要穿衣服。
還得看病
你住的寄養家庭也需要給他們補助。
一開始伊臉娜是從自己工作的社會福利辦公室。
偷偷調配資源
那隨著需求量的增加。
很多猶太父母就會將自己所有的錢。
和孩子一起交給伊臉娜。
所以她必須得做一份名單。
來記錄這些錢財的去向。
一開始這些內容都還記在她腦子裡。
後來太多了
她就只能給寫在紙上。
但是記在紙上肯定會有風險啊？
很容易被發現啊？
對
於是她就將每一個孩子的真實姓名。
以及出來後的假名字。
寄養家庭的地址
用自創的代碼寫在卷顏紙上面。
然後卷成小卷卷 存起來。
當然除了伊臉娜之外。
其他的同僚們也都會進行記錄。
但所有人記錄的都是經過自己手的孩子。
而作為負責人的伊臉娜。
她負責的是將所有的內容會總成一個總名單。
所以伊臉娜是掌握著最多最全信心的那個人。
對
時間就來到了9月份。
9月5號
德軍在華沙城裡面就張貼了一張告示。
就說
凡是有波蘭人願意交出藏匿的猶太人。
那這個波蘭人就可以得到赦免。
當晚消息傳入了格都內部。
格都內的猶太人大概就知道要發生什麼了。
就是想做最後的清洗嗎。
是的
那於是第二天一早。
格都醫院的醫生和護士們。
就聚在一起開會商量對策。
可是會還沒開完
德國人就進入了醫院。
德國黨衛兵就沿著病床開始檢查。
所有不能移動或者是神智不清的病人。
他們就會直接開槍打死。
能走的人
會被他們趕到醫院門口等待。
等待被裝上火車
那阿拉看到這個場景立刻就告訴護士。
通知廚房
讓廚房準備一輛裝食物和空蔬菜箱的卡車。
而他自己則跑到了兒童病房。
當時德軍還沒掃蕩到這。
於是阿拉就組織孩子們派派隊。
孩子們小手牽小手。
護士和阿拉自己手裡面抱著不能走的嬰兒。
30多個孩子就被這樣藏進了裝土豆的卡車裡。
廚房的司機駕駛著卡車飛遲而去。
最終這些孩子們都得救了。
他們被陸續轉移至了格都外面。
當天晚上格都醫院被清空。
到了9月中旬
原本有45萬人的格都。
人口只剩下了6萬多。
其中3萬人是撞牢力。
被德軍留下來勞作的。
而剩下的3萬人則四處躲藏。
他們在地下室和各種廢墟中躲藏了起來。
這個時候還留在這裡的人真的太絕望了。
其實大家都已經知道是怎麼回事了嗎。
納粹都直接進來蓬蓬蓬開槍殺人了。
是的
其實比這更早
格都裡的人就知道那個所謂的勞動營。
就是納粹的殺人集中營了。
因為之前就有猶太人從那倖存了逃出來了。
他就回到了格都
把勞動營裡面發生的一切告訴了大家。
那剩下的這一部分猶太人呢？
就希望能夠有外部力量介入。
你起碼得讓外面的世界知道這裡發生過什麼。
於是有一名信使
就是美國英國方面派來的這麼一個特工。
他就來到了華沙
找到了地下抵抗組織。
就說自己想進到格都內部看一下。
地下抵抗組織就幫忙聯繫上了伊聯納。
就讓伊聯納帶這個人進去。
伊聯納就通過一條運送孩子的地下通道。
把這個信使給帶了進去。
就讓他把這裡的情況給記錄下來嘛？
那和在伊聯納交談的過程當中。
信使就得知了這些人在努力拯救孩子的事。
他應該是把伊聯納他們救孩子的事也傳信回去了吧？
對
這之後1942年12月的一天。
伊聯納能調配的錢也都基本上花光了。
那正當他坐在辦公室的椅子上發愁的時候。
有一個同事名字叫斯泰凡尼亞。
他就過來坐在了伊聯納的對面。
又一種很奇怪的語氣開始和伊聯納打招呼。
這個人是他們知情的吧？
對
他們辦公室的人都是知情的。
但是每個人只知道自己負責的那部分。
並不知道整個事情的全貌。
因為太危險了
斯泰凡尼亞坐下之後就開口提到了。
關於他們拯救有他人這件事。
但是伊聯納是不在辦公室公開聊這個事的。
所以他就特別緊張。
就趕緊打斷了話茶。
這個時候斯泰凡尼亞突然神情嚴肅的就說。
伊聯納你能去一趟。
儒拉維亞街24號三樓四壇園嗎。
去找一位名字叫做特洛伊安的人。
他能助你一臂之力。
說完他扭頭就走了。
似乎是不想讓伊聯納繼續追問下去。
伊聯納坐在椅子上。
聽完他說的之後一臉懵。
他琢磨了一下午
到底是去還是不去啊？
他不信任這個同事嗎。
他信
但是他又不完全相信。
他擔心的是
整件事都是該是太保設計的犬套。
對
去呢又害怕
不去又確實沒錢繼續運營轉移孩子的工作了。
最終他下定決心
還是去吧？
畢竟沒錢是大呀？
他現在籌集的都是救命錢。
等到了地方之後
他先是敲了敲門
屋裡就有一個女人的聲音問。
誰呀？
伊聯納就回答說
我來找特洛伊安的。
房門環環打開
開門的是一個
銀色頭髮的老夫人。
她看起來特別緊張。
原本伊聯納也很緊張嗎。
但她看到對面的這個人很緊張。
她自己就放鬆了不少。
兩個人就往屋子裡面走去。
整間房子啊燈光昏暗。
窗簾緊閉
伊聯納隱約的看見。
房間裡面坐著一個老頭。
正在屋裡面白手讓伊聯納進去。
這個老頭就是開門的這個老夫人的丈夫。
她就是伊聯納要找的特洛伊安。
特洛伊安的本名叫做朱利安。
格羅貝爾尼
他是熱戈塔組織的領袖之一。
熱戈塔組織
對
這個熱戈塔組織是1942年。
有兩名女性天主教徒。
左菲亞和楊創立的。
是一個地下抵抗組織。
最開始的名字叫做猶太人救助委員會。
但是後來為了避免被德軍查到嘛？
就把組織的名字給替換成了一個虛構的人名。
就叫熱戈塔
熱戈塔為什麼會找伊聯納呢？
是上次那個進入格都的特工幫忙聯繫的。
對
但不完全是
其實還有另外一個原因。
當時在格都城內的護士。
我們一直提到了那個阿拉。
他在救下猶太孩子之後。
不只會把孩子送給伊聯納的這個組織。
他會把孩子交給另外一撥人。
哦
所以當時是還有另外一個組織。
也在拯救猶太小孩。
沒錯
這個組織的名字叫RGO。
就是中央福利委員會。
這個委員會是德國官方認證的救助機構。
負責管理難民戰服等等。
但到了1941年。
波蘭的地下組織就滲透進了RGO。
就導致
這裡面的工作人員就在德國人的眼皮子底下。
和波蘭流亡政府以及猶太慈善機構合作。
就將這些救援物資輸送給格都內部的猶太人。
他們走的這些路線和伊聯納他們的路線基本是一致的。
那負責這些工作的名字叫做小丹。
也是一位非常勇敢的女性。
她不僅僅通過RGO組織營救猶太兒童。
她還兼任熱哥塔的兒童部門負責人。
所以伊聯納和小丹這兩個人。
都大概知道有對方這號人。
但是為了安全
他們互相之間也沒有聯繫。
那由於RGO並入了熱哥塔。
並且護士阿拉就告訴他們。
伊聯納的組織面臨著資金短缺的問題。
所以熱哥塔就主動聯繫了伊聯納。
他坐在椅子上的老頭就對伊聯納說。
現在熱哥塔內部所有的地下運動。
都會受到波蘭本土軍的保護。
最重要的是我們有倫敦那邊給的經費。
並且還有很多的安全物。
你可以使用我們的資源。
而且我們也不會干涉你們原本的工作。
太好了 這真的是血中送炭呢？
沒錯
他告訴伊聯納
熱哥塔在華沙街頭有很多的秘密郵箱。
這裡面會定期的放錢。
以後伊聯納可以隨時去那取錢用。
就這樣當伊聯納的組織正式並入熱哥塔之後。
原本負責兒童部門的那個小丹。
他就退出了這個組織。
因為小丹有孩子
他很擔心如果自己掌握了太多的情報。
等哪一天被捕了
納粹會用自己的孩子相威脅。
就這樣伊聯納就接管了整個熱哥塔的兒童部門。
有了錢的伊聯納就繼續擴大救援範圍。
被救下來的十幾歲的猶太青年。
沒有辦法被安排進孤兒院和基養家庭。
於是他們就充當地下信使。
負責穿越地道給大家傳信。
那被救下來的成年人。
則會被安排在安全屋裡。
有了錢的伊聯納租下了兩棟房子。
專門用來藏匿猶太人。
對外就說這是一座結合病療養所。
那慢慢的
伊聯納掌握的資源越來越多。
光是他自己能控制的安全屋就有八九所。
他救下來的人也越來越多。
時間就來到了一九四三年的春天。
這一天凌晨三點多。
伊聯納正在家裡面休息呢？
突然就聽到自家的門被扣響了。
伊聯納驚醒
他第一反應是該是太保。
但是冷靜下來之後又覺得不是。
畢竟該是太保總是聲響很大。
他們絕對不會這樣輕輕的敲門。
那會是誰呢？
伊聯納來不及多想。
他沒有開燈
摸著黑就找到了寫在卷岩紙上面的名單。
按照自己從前演練的步驟。
將卷岩紙從窗戶扔進了後院的垃圾桶裡。
關好窗子之後
他就悄悄的走到了門口。
他輕輕的打開了房門。
門剛開一個縫
伊聯納就從門縫
正好撇見自己對面的鄰居正關門呢？
那不是被看到了
而站在自家門前的是一位猶太女人。
她帶著四個小孩
這四個小孩渾身沾滿了物夠。
頭髮和衣服都濕透了。
但是衣服穿得很整齊。
因為大部分猶太家長把孩子送出來之前。
都會給孩子們穿上最保暖最體面的衣服。
所以伊聯納一看到這些孩子就知道。
他們是剛剛從下水道裡面鑽出來的。
猶太女人就開口說。
喬蘭塔我實在不知道該去哪了。
伊聯納就趕快讓孩子們先進來。
然後關緊了房門
這個猶太女人是負責接應孩子們的人。
一般情況下孩子們從下水道逃出來之後。
向導會把孩子們送到救援網絡當中的某一個負責人那。
然後這些猶太孩子就會被安排進寄養家庭或者是修道院。
但今天他們出現在這肯定是出問題了。
領頭的猶太女人就說。
當天他們按照約定要從下水道轉移孩子。
但當他們趕到的時候。
德國巡邏兵正好出現了。
就有幾名孩子沒逃出來。
還有幾名聯絡員被抓了。
被抓就意味著會遭受酷刑。
伊聯納也不知道被行訊逼供的同事們會交代多少。
她只知道現在這幾個孩子原本要去的安全屋不再安全了。
而她必須在天亮前將這些孩子們送到更安全的地方。
並且剛剛她開門的時候。
對面的那個鄰居已經看到了這幾個滿身無垢的猶太人。
如果鄰居告密
那自己所剩的時間就更少了。
說吧？
她就開始準備給孩子們洗澡。
就為什麼一定要洗澡呢？
就是因為當時葛都內部的傷寒肆虐。
孩子們從下水道爬出來。
身上一定攜帶了病毒。
如果不及時洗乾淨。
就很容易造成大規模的傳染。
而且身上這麼髒
你就很容易暴露身份啊？
伊聯納一邊燒熱水。
一邊就拿出了家裡剩下的一小塊肥皂。
用力的洗著孩子們的衣服。
等到這塊肥皂用完。
要去拿新肥皂的時候。
她就發現家裡已經沒有肥皂了。
在戰時的華沙
肥皂是非常珍貴的。
在這個時候
伊聯納的媽媽紋身起來了。
她就趕快讓媽媽給自己找肥皂。
媽媽翻遍了家裡
就找來了一塊薄薄的。
已經馬上就要用完了的肥皂。
這肯定不夠給這四個小孩洗澡呀？
於是伊聯納就想碰碰運氣。
她在凌晨三點多
敲響了鄰居的房門。
有肥皂嗎
我睡不著我要洗衣服。
說完啊？
鄰居老奶奶就轉身進屋。
不一會就拿出了一塊。
用紙包裹著的肥皂。
伊聯納說謝謝
回應她的是一句別客氣。
第二天一早
友台女人就帶著孩子們去到了伊聯納。
聯絡的新的安全屋。
而伊聯納則聽到鄰居們正在議論。
自己家半夜發出來的動靜。
昨晚那個給伊聯納借肥皂的阿姨。
大聲的在巷子裡面就嚷嚷。
哎呀？
她丈夫被德國人抓到集中營裡了。
她大晚上的睡不著。
哭得私心烈飛的
啊是嗎
鄰居們七嘴八舌的議論著。
那還有假
不僅半夜爬起來洗衣服。
還來我家借肥皂的把我都給吵醒了。
伊聯納知道鄰居阿姨已經發現了自己的秘密。
而她現在正大聲嚷嚷的給自己打掩護呢？
其實從這件事也能看出來。
就是在人性或者是生死面前。
所謂的宗教衝突或者是文化差異。
好像都不是什麼特別大的問題了。
伊聯納是波蘭人
他信奉天主教
若格塔的兩位創始人。
他也信奉天主教
包括阿陽和那些願意接受猶太孩子的波蘭家庭。
他們原本可能也會因為宗教的衝突。
或者是政治立場的對立不喜歡猶太人。
但是當猶太人遭到納粹這種反人類的屠殺暴行的時候。
大家也都會伸出援手幫一把。
是的
那就在這幾個孩子逃出來之後。
沒幾天
格都內還沒有被送上火車的年輕猶太人們。
準備奮力一搏
我們進入第五章
格都起義
經歷過1942年夏天開始的大驅逐之後。
剩下的猶太人漸漸的就明白了。
押韻他們的火車是開向那的。
1943年1月18號。
這一天德軍奉命進入格都開始新一輪的驅逐。
但他們不知道的是。
從冬天開始
剩下一部分猶太人就決定要展開武力抵抗。
年輕的小伙子聚在一起。
用能找到的材料製作燃燒彈。
年輕的女孩子們偷偷運送炸藥和槍枝。
大家一起架過了樓頂作為自己的陣地。
當德軍再次來到格都的時候。
猶太人們就開槍了。
德軍是促不及防啊？
他們被猶太人竟然會反抗這件事。
震驚的是木燈口袋。
一時間沒反應過來。
這次反擊的結果是肯定的。
面對軍備完善的德軍。
這些年輕人是不可能去得勝利的。
戰爭持續了四天
最終所有的反抗者都犧牲了。
又有五千多人被送上了火車。
這次反抗之後
德軍就徹底封鎖了格都。
伊聯娜他們的通行證也都失效了。
外部人員也沒有辦法再進入格都。
猶太人們只能靠自己的能力逃出來了。
不過伊聯娜在牆外。
為逃脫的猶太人們安排好了接應。
他在華沙全城設置了很多信箱。
如果有人需要安全物或者是醫生的幫助。
只要有需求都可以來到這個信箱裡面留言。
此外他還聯繫了一些咖啡館。
逃出來的猶太人就可以去這些咖啡館裡街頭。
營救的陣仗很大
很快德軍就盯上了伊聯娜以及热戈塔組織。
4月4號我們先前提到的。
把伊聯娜介紹給热戈塔的同事斯特凡尼亞。
嗯
他被德軍抓住了
儘管他遭受到了無盡的酷刑折磨。
但他卻沒有供出任何人。
最終他被德軍殺害。
還有先前提到的雅家。
當時他家中藏著好幾名成年的猶太人。
以及一些猶太孩子。
這段時間他家附近有一名德國人死了。
於是德軍就開始搜索整個街區。
當時整個街區都封起來了。
沒有人能夠從這逃走。
兩隊士兵從街道兩側向中間推進。
而雅家的家正好在這條街的正中間。
當時他已經做好了必死的準備了。
他手裡握著孩子們的名單站在火爐旁。
準備在德軍進來的第一時間。
就把這個名單扔進火堆裡。
但沒想到的是
因為雅家家就在這個正中間嘛？
兩隊士兵都以為對方搜索過這戶人家了。
所以他們在雅家的家門口碰頭之後就走了。
這太驚險了
是的
當天雅家就聽說
他們這條街上有一戶鄰居家藏了五個猶太男人。
被發現後
這些猶太人以及收留他們的房主都被舊地出死了。
而格都牆壞呢？
德軍加大了搜索力度。
格都內部經過了上一次小規模的反抗之後。
氣氛變得非常緊張。
大家知道
剩下的這些人遲早也會被送上火車。
到了4月18號
這一天是天主教的復活節前夜。
也是猶太人的愉悅節前夜。
這天華沙城裡的集市和遊樂場。
比平時要更熱鬧一些。
遊樂場裡有一座摩天輪。
摩天輪升到最高處。
就能從這個最高處看到格都的內部。
這段時間
伊聯娜收到了消息。
德國人準備再一次驅逐猶太人了。
那這次剩下不多的猶太人就準備和德軍疏死一搏。
那事實上在上次起義之後。
剩下的猶太人就已經開始準備這場戰鬥了。
消息很快就傳到了格都牆壞。
伊聯娜所在的熱格塔組織。
也通過地下通道送進去了很多的彈藥和應急物資。
4月18號當晚
猶太人知道了第二天德軍要再次進入格都。
於是他們就開始收拾東西。
先讓老人孩子們躲進格樓和地下岩體裡。
而年輕人們則拿上物資。
等上了各個建築物的格樓準備戰鬥。
19日凌晨兩點半。
德國軍隊包圍了格都。
上次吃了別之後
德國人為這次的驅逐做足了準備。
但在他們看來
這也不過就是一次普通的清教行動。
而德軍的行徑早就被猶太偵察員匯包給抵抗組織了。
大約有750名全副武裝的猶太青年。
正在等待著德軍的進入。
阿拉在格都的醫院被銷毀之後。
被德國人安排到了格都內部的工廠裡面做縫任工。
專門給德軍做軍裝。
他一直都還沒走
對 還活著就好
那當阿拉知道了大家要武裝反抗之後。
他就趕忙找到了一個地下室。
建立起了新的地下醫療點。
給受傷的戰士們處理傷口。
時間來到了早上
德國部隊進入格都後就遭到了猶太抵抗者的攻擊。
猶太抵抗者利用有限的武器開始還擊。
德國人完全沒有料到。
他們眼中的獵等民族竟然還會反抗。
還會有規模的反抗。
於是雙方就陷入了激戰。
經過了一整天的戰鬥。
德軍的坦克被燃燒品和手榴彈點燃。
德軍被迫後退
在起義的第一天
猶太抵抗者們獲得了勝利。
下午無電 德軍撤出了格都。
格都地下室內的臨時醫療點。
有傷員被源源不斷的運送過來。
當天就有將近兩百個猶太人在戰鬥當中死亡。
但當時整個格都沉浸在擊退敵人的興奮當中。
每個人都互相擁抱。
儘管他們知道這次的反抗是徒勞的。
不可能有真正的勝利。
但他們仍然為這次戰鬥做足了準備。
奉獻了所有
第二天 德軍在午後又開始組織了進攻。
猶太人提前精心步入的地雷。
在德軍腳下爆炸
誓死如歸的女孩子們。
將手榴彈藏在裙子下面。
在最後一刻拋向德軍的坦克。
很快 格都起義的消息就傳到了牆外。
大量的華沙居民們就排著隊。
想登上那座摩天輪。
大家手裡拿著為復活節準備的食物。
登上能夠看到格都內部的大橋上面去野餐。
每個人都想登高
好好地觀賞一下這次精彩絕倫的戰鬥。
大部分的人其實並不是在為猶太人搖起那喊。
而是幸在樂禍的欣賞德國人吃別的場面。
格都內部的炮火聲四起。
伴隨著火光
成為了華沙居民們復活節的慶祝節目。
在起義的第六天
格都內的戰局開始逆轉。
德國人下決心要暴力鎮壓。
緊接著他們開始將一棟棟的樓房點燃。
煙霧和灰塵飄到了牆外。
日葛塔成員開始準備接應逃出來的猶太倖存者。
伊列納當時準備了很多的安全屋。
在德軍忙著點燃建築物的時候。
艾爾卡從下水道進入了格都內部。
一棟一棟地搜索著倖存者。
然後將倖存者輸送到牆外的各個安全屋裡。
伊列納呢一直等候在下水道口。
一個一個的接應逃出來的猶太人。
每出來一個女人
伊列納就會仔細的看一看是不是阿拉。
那就這樣
轉移工作持續了一兩週。
很多家庭從下水道裡面逃了出來。
但伊列納始終沒有見到阿拉的影子。
她是不是還一直在牆裡面救人呢？
是的
最終呢德軍發現了這些密道。
他們切斷了這些同道。
並向下水道和煤氣管道裡面投毒。
以此來堵住逃亡路線。
等到5月初的時候。
所有的通道都被發現了。
基本沒有人能夠從格都裡面逃出來了。
5月8號呢德軍搜查了阿拉建立的臨時醫療點。
因為這個醫療點是在地下嘛？
所以德軍一直都沒發現。
但在做最終的掃蕩時。
德軍帶上了軍犬
狗很快就聞到了地下室裡面藏著人。
就這樣阿拉和其他的醫療人員。
加上醫療點中的病患被逮捕了。
那阿拉他們就
被逮走了
那能動的就被壓上了火車。
送到了集中營
不能動的就就地處決。
到了5月10號
登上摩天輪關站的華沙居民。
看到格都內猶太人掛起來的大床單。
上面寫著
兄弟們請救救我們。
我們為你們的自由和我們自己的自由而戰。
但華沙居民並沒有伸出援手。
他們不知道的是
格都內部的戰火很快就會蔓延到牆外。
在這場戰爭當中
根本就不會有倖存者。
到了5月16日晚上8點15。
一聲巨大的爆炸聲。
震碎了房屋的玻璃。
格都內的猶太會堂轟然倒塌。
至此這場戰役結束了。
原本還剩6萬左右人口的格都。
有56，065人死於這場戰鬥。
從這一刻起
華沙格都不復存在。
當猶太區域被移為平地之後。
藏匿在華沙的猶太人們就陷入了絕望。
華沙城中當時有很多的反猶分子。
他們四處搜查
倖存的猶太人想要敲詐他們。
不給錢就舉報你
就舉報給德國人
在這樣的處境之下。
就讓很多倖存下來的猶太人。
感到非常痛苦壓力很大。
確實
不知道什麼時候
城裡面開始出現了一些很離奇的傳聞。
有人說德軍願意用猶太人交換。
身在國外的德國公民。
就類似於人質交換。
這些猶太人會乘坐著普通的列車離開波蘭。
很快這個消息就傳到了各個安全屋內的。
猶太人耳朵裡
很多人都準備挺而走險。
花上大價錢申請這個名額。
第一批猶太人很快就被送去了法國。
隨後他們還忌諱了自己已經安全了的信件。
隨即超過2500名的猶太人。
從各個安全屋裡面蜂擁而出。
所有人都開始爭奪出境的名額。
當時伊聯娜以及其他的波蘭地下組織成員。
都在提醒猶太人
這可能是一個陷阱。
但沒有人能聽得進去。
畢竟這個誘惑真的很大。
是啊？
最終這些人被分批帶走。
一大部分人被送到了集中營。
剩下的人被就地處決。
其實整件事都是精心策劃的。
有幾個猶太監商和蓋世太保進行合作。
設計了這個圈套
這件事之後呢？
德國人就發現
竟然有這麼多猶太人都躲在華沙城裡。
於是他們開始認真的調查起了地下組織。
很快他們就查到了熱格塔。
我們進入第六章
被捕
在格都東邊的一條街上沒有一家洗衣店。
平時的生意很好
整日裡都有很多的女人進進出出。
每個人手裡都會拿一個裝著髒衣服的大籃子。
或者是一個大大的牛皮紙袋。
其中有一些是送來清洗的衣服。
這些衣服裡面會藏著幾封密信。
或者是幾章寫著暗號的小紙條。
哦 這個洗衣店是一個地下聯絡點。
對
1943年10月。
蓋世太保登門
帶走了洗衣店的老闆。
在嚴酷的行訊之下。
店老闆供出了波蘭地下抵抗組織中的三個人。
其中有一個人就是伊聯娜。
10月9日的夜裡。
蓋世太保來到了伊聯娜家。
帶走了她
當天晚上
楊卡正在伊聯娜家做客。
楊卡就是我們先前提到了那個雅嘉。
她的妹妹
雅嘉和楊卡家
也是一個很重要的藏匿猶太人的據點。
當時伊聯娜被抓走的時候。
蓋世太保並沒有抓住楊卡。
伊聯娜就認為
德國人應該是沒有掌握很多情報。
對 畢竟楊卡和雅嘉。
這兩個人也是抵抗組織當中非常重要的人物。
對
被抓走的伊聯娜就坐在車上。
她的手裡摸到了我們最開始說的。
一張寫著《安全屋地址》的卷顏紙。
她看向窗外
這個時候車子馬上就要開到。
蓋世太保的總部 舒查大街了。
沒時間了呀？
伊聯娜用力的碾碎了薄薄的卷顏紙。
然後她鑽著紙屑
將手伸出了車窗之外。
在蓋世太保的寒聲當中。
紙片隨著風消失在了華沙街頭。
車子很快就開到了舒查大街。
伊聯娜在簡單的登記之後。
就被帶到了一間審訊室。
一個穿著大皮靴的德國軍官就進來了。
問了他一些簡單的問題。
你叫什麼名字啊？
家住哪啊？
家裡都有什麼人啊？
問完之後
德國軍官就對伊聯娜說。
我們知道你在幫助地下抵抗組織和猶太人。
你在為哪個組織工作呢？
坦白交代對你有好處。
一邊說
德軍一邊念出了好幾個自己同事的名字。
面對這樣的情境
伊聯娜堅承自己什麼都不知道。
自己只是一個社工。
那些人都是自己做社工的時候認識的同事。
眼見伊聯娜什麼都不說。
德國軍官就對他說。
那就隨你吧？
咱們後會有期
說完他就離開了房間。
這之後伊聯娜就被轉移到了一所監獄。
據監獄的倖存者說。
所有來到這所監獄的人。
第一天都會遭受到最殘酷的毆打。
對於德軍來說
這樣子做事的效率最高。
一般經過獨打之後。
很多人就會開始交代情報了。
獨打的方式有很多。
每一種都是完全沒有人性的。
至於伊聯娜本人在監獄裡面。
遭受到了什麼樣具體的刑罰。
我們也不得而知
但讓伊聯娜感到欣慰的是。
他在這家監獄裡面遇到了幾位老朋友。
他們也都是因為參與地下抵抗運動而被抓進來的。
這些人迅速的就在監獄裡面形成了一個小小的聯盟。
大家互相支撐彼此鼓勵。
監獄中每天早上8點半是處決時間。
每天德國軍人都會來帶走一些人。
然後就是早飯時間。
大家會吃一些發美的麵包和一些咖啡。
正當大家吃飯的時候。
突然就有人點名
伊聯娜現在趕進去牙科診所就診。
牙科診所
自己昨天確實被打得不清。
但是牙也確實沒事。
伊聯娜剛要張嘴說自己的牙沒事。
話還沒說出來
他恍然大悟
這是一個信號
有人在給自己傳達信號。
走進牙科診所之後。
伊聯娜就認出來了。
這個牙醫就是自己曾經的同事安娜。
安娜是依伊聯娜躺到椅子上。
為了不引起懷疑
安娜不得不在伊聯娜健康的牙齒上開始鑽動。
當附近的德國預警放鬆警惕的時候。
安娜將一個小指團塞到了伊聯娜手裡。
這個指條就是那個熱額塔的領袖。
老頭特洛伊安送進來的。
上面寫著一句話
我們正竭盡全力救你脫離地獄。
伊聯娜草草地回覆了四個字。
名單安全
但名單在哪兒它並沒有寫下來。
萬一這張指條被解惑了那麻煩可就大了。
現在存在腦子裡才是最安全的。
嗯
日子一天一天過去。
伊聯娜每天都要被拉去審訊。
她的腿已經被打斷了。
身上也有無數的傷口。
但她一直咬死說自己是一個社工。
之所以伊聯娜沒有被打死。
是因為其實德國人並不知道自己抓的是誰。
所有人都認為
這個身高一米五的伊聯娜。
只是一個無足輕重的小角色。
在伊聯娜被捕之後。
楊卡就帶著名單找到了雅當。
她擔心伊聯娜會堅持不住。
供出自己和雅當
要是這樣的話
雅當藏身的安全屋就不安全了。
於是她趕緊帶著名單。
把雅當藏到了另外一處安全屋裡。
雅當聽說了伊聯娜被蓋士太保帶走。
她內心非常痛苦
精神也邊臨崩潰
她的嘴裡面不斷的都囊著。
我們得救她我們得救她。
於是雅當和楊卡
找到了熱格塔的領袖特洛伊安。
雅當苦苦的哀求特洛伊安。
要救救伊聯娜
最終特洛伊安同意了。
他說熱格塔會試著營救伊聯娜。
他們先是想辦法把紙條送進去。
告訴伊聯娜組織並沒有放棄她。
隨後的日子裡
特洛伊安一直利用紙條和伊聯娜保持聯繫。
但時間來到了1944年的1月。
這時距離伊聯娜被抓已經有兩個多月了。
她其實已經快要堅持不住了。
不僅身體遭受到了非人的折磨。
她的精神也邊臨崩潰了。
自從她進來
身邊的同事們就一個接一個的被處決。
她每天都要逼迫自己不要想名單的事。
不要想楊卡不要想雅當。
她擔心自己會在邊臨崩潰的時候。
不自覺的說出這些人的名字。
有一天伊聯娜照舊來到了亞裔城市。
今天交給她的紙條不再是主負她堅持了。
紙條上面寫著
堅強一些我們愛你。
這句話的意思在伊聯娜看起來很明顯的。
組織已經放棄了自己。
1944年1月20號這一天。
早上8點半的處決名單中。
伊聯娜的名字荷蘭在列。
德軍發現
他們並不會從伊聯娜的嘴裡面問出什麼。
所以準備直接殺掉她。
就這樣伊聯娜被壓往舒查大街。
同行的人都被帶到了一個等候室。
所有人都在哭泣
接著一個女人的名字被點到。
她被帶到了等候室左邊的那扇門。
這扇門通向行刑的庭院。
門被關上之後
緊接著傳來了碰的一聲腔響。
一個人 兩個人 三個人。
終於輪到伊聯娜了。
她站起來朝左邊的門走了過去。
突然德國士兵試一塌。
走右邊的門進行進一步審訊。
伊聯娜此時已經崩潰了。
她甚至更希望自己能夠走向左邊的門結束這一切。
那右邊的門後面有一名德國軍人正在等著她。
她命令伊聯娜跟上自己。
她帶著伊聯娜一路就走了出來。
來到了舒查大街和自由大刀的交叉口。
然後這名德國軍人就對她說。
你自由了 快逃跑吧？
啊 這是得救了
是的 其實熱哥塔一直都沒有放棄伊聯娜。
他們從伊聯娜被抓之後。
就明確了要救她出來的目標。
這怎麼救的呀？
這所監獄管理森嚴。
此前根本沒有人能夠從裡面逃出來。
所以想要救伊聯娜只有一個方法。
那就是直接賄賂蓋士太堡。
嗯 這確實是
此招虛現勝算缺大呀？
是啊？
熱哥塔這個虛構的人名。
一直都是蓋士太堡同級令上的第一名。
結果他們卻要主動聯繫他們。
這個計畫聽起來太可怕了。
但沒辦法 關鍵時期必須得這麼做。
熱哥塔也願意承擔賄賂蓋士太堡的費用。
但怎麼能聯繫上蓋士太堡呢？
你總不能直接跑到樹叉大街裡面去問吧？
得先找靠譜的中間人。
別一露面直接被抓了。
是的 得找一個在蓋士太堡內部有關係的。
波蘭人牽線搭橋
伊聯娜的辦公室裡面就有一位女同事。
名字叫做瑪利亞
她這麼多年一直負責和蓋士太堡周旋。
就相當於一個公關的角色。
每周她都會和蓋士太堡們一起打牌。
同時她還為伊聯娜負責的地下抵抗組織效力。
那瑪利亞表面上和蓋士太堡的關係不錯。
但實際上 不僅自己是抵抗組織的人。
她的丈夫 兒子 全家都是抵抗組織的人。
甚至她家裡面就還藏著好幾個猶太人。
表面上是黑白通吃。
實則是身在曹穎心在汗。
瑪利亞輾轉就通過好幾層關係。
終於聯繫到了負責行行的蓋士太堡。
為了換取伊聯娜的生命。
熱戈塔支付了他們組織史上最昂貴的贖金。
大概是3.5萬
就相當於現在的10萬美金。
那真的挺多了
是啊 其實並不是所有人都有伊聯娜的這個待遇。
剛剛我們講過嘛？
當時監獄裡面有很多他們的同事。
都被一個接一個的處決了。
事實上 每一個人在監獄裡面都會收到組織的紙條。
一般這個上面都會寫一些話來給他們信心。
當然 大家也會通過這個紙條傳遞各種各樣的重要信息。
但組織並不會付出這麼多去救每一個人。
那為啥伊聯娜是那個特別的人呢？
原因就是那份被救下的猶太兒童名單。
當伊聯娜被送到監獄的第二天一早。
特洛伊安就趕緊傳進來紙條問名單怎麼樣了。
當時伊聯娜回覆說名單安全。
對 但是她沒說名單在哪。
而當時拿到名單的陽卡。
也沒和別人說自己手裡拿著這份名單。
況且陽卡手裡的這份名單其實也是不全的。
最全的都在伊聯娜的腦袋裡呢？
所以在熱哥塔看來。
他們非常擔心伊聯娜會扛不住折磨供出名單。
如果那樣的話 不僅名單上的孩子們很危險。
他們整個組織都會很危險。
是的 那除此之外 他們還有第二層考慮。
就算伊聯娜真的扛住了折磨 什麼都沒說。
最後在監獄裡面犧牲了。
那就再也沒有人能找到這份名單了。
被救出來的猶太孩子們。
也就再也找不回自己的真實身份了。
嗯 在這樣非常艱難的時刻。
伊聯娜和熱哥塔
他們不僅想讓這些孩子活下來。
還考慮到了他們未來如何活下去的問題。
對 那就這樣
熱哥塔決定通過瑪麗亞簽的這條線。
給蓋世泰堡送錢
那派誰去送錢呢？
瑪麗亞14歲的女兒承擔了這項任務。
她將一卷一卷的現金放在了書包的底部。
去到了交易點 把錢放了下來。
其實大家很擔心 蓋世泰堡收了錢卻不辦事。
畢竟就算他們實演了 也拿他們一點辦法都沒有。
但是沒想到
這個人真的在最後關頭把伊聯娜給放了。
那從此 伊聯娜這個名字。
在德國人的官方記錄上已經是一個死掉的人了。
那解馬以後
他們就不會再想著抓伊聯娜了。
嗯 被放走的伊聯娜渾身是血。
她的腿已經斷了 站都站不穩。
一時間她根本不知道該往哪走。
她就走進了附近的一家藥店。
女店主看到她這副樣子。
就趕快把她帶到了後屋洗了洗。
找到了一件乾淨的衣服套在了她的球服上面。
最後還給了她幾塊錢 讓她去坐電車。
那此時伊聯娜的腦袋已經不轉了。
她本能的就搭上了回媽媽家的五路電車。
車正在開的路上 突然有一個少年就大喊了一聲。
有蓋世泰堡快點下車。
車就停了下來 蓋世泰堡從前門上車檢查。
乘客們都擠到了後門一擁而下。
伊聯娜卻著腿也被擠到了車後面。
但是她走不快只能一點一點挪步子。
那別人都在跑 這個時候就你一個人慢悠悠的。
就非常顯眼 伊聯娜心裡緊張急了。
這個時候有一位剛剛下車的老人挺下了腳步。
然後牽住了伊聯娜的手 把她扶下了車。
其實老人應該能看出來。
滿身傷痕的伊聯娜是抵抗組織的人。
她就想幫她一把
那下車之後 伊聯娜就拖著斷腿。
跌跌撞撞地走回了家。
回到家後 她伊聯魂睡了好幾天。
這幾天裡 街上的告示牌上面貼出了一張。
帶有她名字的告示 公告。
伊聯娜森德勒1944年1月20日已被槍決。
罪名 協助猶太人。
事實上 這個時候伊聯娜待在自己家是很危險的。
畢竟該是太保每天都在到處搜查。
這會兒伊聯娜的媽媽已經冰得很嚴重了。
原本就身體不好了她。
在聽說女兒被抓的消息之後 冰得更重。
所以伊聯娜很不想走 她不忍心丟下媽媽。
那為了躲避搜查
她還搬進了自己樓上的鄰居家贊助。
然後每一天都抽幾分鐘時間回家看看媽媽。
那這次如果走了
那就真的要換一個地方了 隱姓埋名的生活了。
也就意味著自己有可能再也見不到媽媽了。
所以伊聯娜一直在猶豫。
在這期間 楊卡經常來到她家裡。
讓她快點走 特羅伊安也來信催促她。
有一天該是太保又來了。
他們來到了伊聯娜家一頓搜查。
伊聯娜躲在樓上的鄰居家。
聽著脾穴的聲音 石進石遠 最終離去。
這時鄰居家的門打開了。
是她的表親
伊聯娜不在的時候 一直都是這個表親照顧她的媽媽。
她推開門緊緊的擁抱了一下伊聯娜。
往她手裡塞了一張紙條。
然後對著伊聯娜的耳朵說。
你必須得走了 保重 說完她就轉身離去。
伊聯娜展開手裡的指團。
上面是媽媽寫給她的一句話。
他們又來搜捕你了 你千萬不能靠近。
哪怕跟我道別也不行 儘快離開。
但是太保已經知道她還逃走了。
對 而且原本他們並不在乎伊聯娜。
但能讓抵抗組織大廢周章救出來的人。
一定是一個重要角色呀？
所以德國人發現她逃走了之後。
就搜捕得更加仔細了。
就這樣 沒有選擇的伊聯娜踏上了逃亡之路。
組織為她重新辦了新的身份證。
名字叫做克拉拉
為了躲避追查
她還將自己的頭髮染成了紅色。
輾轉在各個安全屋裡躲避蓋世太保。
在逃亡的路上 伊聯娜不停地整理著名單。
她和雅家、楊卡姐妹以及雅當。
將所有能記起來的名字都存放在了一個大大的玻璃罐裡面。
埋在了楊卡家後院的蘋果樹下面。
戰火還在蔓延
伊聯娜化名克拉拉繼續惹她的地下抵抗工作。
第七章 最後的火光。
1944年 伊聯娜已經是熱戈塔的領導層了。
7月份 德國人在東縣節節敗退。
蘇聯紅軍也已經推進到了維斯瓦河對面。
這條維斯瓦河直接穿過華沙。
只要過了河就是華沙的市區。
波蘭的地下抵抗組織就判斷。
德國人很可能會撤離華沙。
而蘇聯人會從東面配合作戰。
他們要搶在外部勢力之前。
自己先一步解放華沙。
於是 華沙起義被定在了1944年8月1日。
下午5點發動
最初成立出現過一種勝利的幻覺。
第一天和第二天 雖然有很多起義軍犧牲。
但起義軍也擊斃了不少的德國士兵。
當時大家都沉浸在即將勝利的喜悅當中。
因為蘇聯紅軍已經抵達維斯瓦河。
所有人都認為蘇聯人一定會伸出援手。
但此時華沙人不知道。
德國人已經決定不惜一切代價守住這座城市。
柏林下達的命令是殺光所有居民。
再把華沙推平
而且蘇聯當時也沒有過河呀？
是的 蘇聯它是有自己的心思的。
當時波蘭的流亡政府的據點在英國。
所以他們的政策其實是偏向於西方的。
對於蘇聯來說
直接幫波蘭人把德軍趕走。
那不就相當於把波蘭直接送給流亡政府嗎？
所以蘇聯紅軍即使已經出現在華沙家門口了。
但也沒有渡河支援。
他們不僅沒渡河支援。
還拒絕讓英美盟軍的飛機使用蘇聯機場。
為華沙空頭物資
這就導致盟軍的飛機必須得從意大利遠距離起飛。
補給效率極低
而大部分物資還落入了德軍的手裡。
當然 蘇聯方面對此的解釋是說。
他們也曾經嘗試過河。
但是被德軍的裝甲部隊給擊退了。
那個時候 蘇軍剛剛經歷一場超長距離的進攻。
此時補給線跟不上。
士兵們已經疲憊不堪了。
好吧？
這之後 德國空軍就開始轟炸華沙。
波蘭是根本沒有任何防空能力的。
戰爭持續了幾天之後。
德國人重新掌握主動權。
並開始在城內屠殺平民。
接下來的日子裏 各種形式的處決便不在華沙街頭。
伊聯娜此前救出來的一些猶太孩子。
也都死於這場屠殺。
格都的毀滅 最終同步到了整個華沙。
伊聯娜和亞當以及楊卡雅加姐妹就被迫逃離。
他們最後躲進了一處建築工地的廢墟裏面。
剛剛找到落腳店
他們就做了一個決定。
得做點什麼呀 不能乾等著。
伊聯娜有護士和社會工作的經驗。
雅加和楊卡也懂醫療。
於是第二天
他們就在廢墟裏面建立起了一個臨時野戰醫院。
救治受傷的抵抗者和平民。
這間醫院裏面沒有足夠的藥品。
沒有完整的氣血 也沒有安全的病房。
但是不久 有很多人都聚集了過來。
有的人負責找水 負責搬運商員。
還有很多人主動 負責處理傷口。
受傷的人越來越多。
這個廢墟裏臨時醫院的規模也越來越大。
但是亞當他是沒有救護的經驗的。
而且他已經在藏身處躲了好幾年了。
他不想再躲了
於是他就決定參戰。
對伊聯娜來說 他是很難接受亞當的決定的。
他好不容易和亞當團聚。
現在卻要看著他去送死。
可是也沒辦法
因為在那個時候
每個人都在做自己力所能及的事。
當時伊聯娜不僅要保護自己。
他還得想辦法保護隊伍當中的猶太人。
食物和水越來越少。
城市的秩序也在崩潰。
安全區域被縮的越來越小。
到了9月初 華沙起義敗局已定。
9月9日 德國的飛機開始在空中盤旋。
向居民散發傳單
要求他們撤離到德國處理中心報道。
不去的就會被處決。
到了9月11日
德國人帶著噴火器和燃燒裝置。
來到了這間臨時醫院所在的街區。
他們要把剩下的建築全部燒掉。
德國人發現他們之後就把他們趕了出去。
壓進了前往處理中心的人群當中。
這個時候過去就是死路一條啊？
納粹現在已經完全瘋了。
是的
尤其在這個時候
伊莲娜又受了傷
她在街上尋找物資的時候就遇見了德軍。
被德軍用刀刺傷了大腿。
此時的亞當也回來了。
她和其他的夥伴們都非常擔心伊莲娜的腿傷。
因為她的傷口一直在流濃。
如果繼續拖下去的話。
很可能就會引發敗血症。
但伊莲娜更擔心的是那些同行的猶太人。
因為此時他們的隊伍裡面有幾名猶太孩子。
她必須想辦法讓他們和大部隊一起離開。
而且還不能被德國人識破身份。
最終他們決定去賄賂一名德國看獸。
幾個人把身上還能拿出來的錢財都湊在了一起。
交給了那個德國人。
對方收下之後給他們指了一個方向。
讓他們朝城外去
就這樣伊莲娜、亞當、楊卡、亞家。
帶著幾個猶太孩子們一起一直向南走。
最終逃出了華沙
到了1944年10月。
華沙起義徹底失敗。
等到1945年1月。
蘇聯軍隊進入華沙的時候。
華沙80%的建築被毀。
戰爭並沒有完全結束。
華沙人能做的就是。
清點損失尋找親人。
同時去面臨一個新的不確定的時代。
此時呢？
伊莲娜和亞當已經回到了華沙。
他們在一所醫療站裡面。
繼續為這座城市貢獻著自己的力量。
過了沒多久
1945年5月8號。
德國簽署投降書
戰爭終於結束了
伊莲娜則回到了城市福利辦公室。
開始重建社會救濟體系。
她很快就被任命為全市福利服務負責人。
倖存者的消息也陸續傳過來了。
有時伊莲娜會在街上碰見自己昔日。
一起戰鬥的朋友
他們在戰亂當中失去了對方的消息。
甚至都以為對方已經死了。
當他們重逢的時候。
那種看到對方也活下來的喜悅。
讓他們緊緊的擁抱在一起。
然後他們會鼓勵對方。
以後要好好的活下去。
不要沉溺於過去
要忘掉過去的痛苦。
戰後伊莲娜和亞當也沒有馬上恢復原來的身份。
他們依然使用假名字生活。
伊莲娜和亞當收養了兩個猶太女孩。
其他被救下來的孩子呢？
也開始各自尋找親人。
或者是被他們的養父母正式收養。
很多孩子在戰中當中被迫使用新名字新身份。
還被迫信仰新的宗教。
那戰爭結束之後
他們到底該回哪生活呢？
要跟誰生活呢？
是否要恢復猶太身份呢？
這都變成了非常複雜的問題。
第八章 倖存的孩子。
1945年春天
伊莲娜和童伴一起回到了雅家舊宅的後花園。
尋找買在那兒的兒童名單。
可是房子已經在華沙奇異當中被炸毀了。
花園裡面到處都是磚塊 瓦利和雜草。
他們帶著鏟子找了好幾個小時。
最終還是沒有找到這份名單。
名單 伊莲娜暫時的日記和賬本。
都在華沙奇異的大火當中消失了。
但是伊莲娜並沒有放棄。
她和同事們開始憑記憶重建名單。
這份名單一定是不完整的。
一定還有一些孩子們的名字被遺忘了。
但他們在盡自己最大的努力重建這份名單。
最後根據伊莲娜和同事們的統計。
他們至少就下了2500名兒童。
在戰爭剛開始的時候。
波蘭大概有340萬猶太人。
其中有一百萬是兒童。
後面根據猶太大屠殺紀念館的記錄。
在二戰之後
只有5000個孩子最後倖存了下來。
當時波蘭國內有很多地下組織。
都在營救這些猶太人。
伊莲娜所領導的組織救的孩子應該是最多的。
後來伊莲娜把這份名單交給了。
戰後負責猶太事務的同事保存。
直到近些年
還有猶太生存者是憑記了這份名單。
找到他們自己的家人的。
那之前你說嘛？
在戰時這麼困難的時刻。
伊莲娜還想到要留下這些孩子們的身份信息。
不僅是要幫他們活下來。
還得幫他們繼續活下去。
確實是這樣的
這份名單在戰後的五六十年又救了他們一次。
那些被救出來的孩子們都被送到了基養家庭。
在那他們開始面臨新的生活。
有的孩子們在基養家庭生活得很幸福。
養父母會把他們當作自己的親生孩子一樣對待。
給他們很多的愛
但有些孩子他們去到了新的家庭。
也會遇到各種各樣的問題。
土西亞就是被從格都救出來的一個女孩。
她在四歲的時候被送到了基養家庭。
這個年紀的孩子已經開始寄事了。
當時她去到基養家庭的時候滿身都是獅子。
身上還有很多的潰瘍。
在這麼狼狽的樣子。
讓她很自卑
一下子就有一種寄人離下的感覺。
土西亞是出生在平民窟。
不到一歲的時候
她就和父母一起進入了格都。
原本她有一個妹妹。
妹妹是在格都裡面出生的。
但是當時大家都藏在地下岩體裡面。
躲避德軍的搜查
新生兒一生下來就會哭。
大家為了不讓這個嬰兒發出聲音。
暴露位置
就活活的悶死了這個孩子。
土西亞目睹了這一切。
格都裡的生活就讓土西亞有了晚上尿床的習慣。
這應該是一種應激反應。
是的
而當她去到基養家庭的時候。
她的羊母會因為她晚上尿床這件事而打她。
在整個成長過程當中。
她的羊母就對她非常冷漠。
土西亞能明顯的感覺到。
羊母並沒有那麼愛她。
那麼土西亞將這一切合理化的解釋就是。
親生孩子和生養的孩子就是不一樣。
人就是不會像愛親生孩子一樣。
愛收養的孩子的
所以她還是認為是自己的問題。
是的
因為土西亞被救出來的時候已經四歲了。
她知道自己是猶太人。
也知道自己是被救出來的。
所以她一直想找自己的親生媽媽。
那每當有新的被營救的名單放出來的時候。
她都會去看有沒有自己媽媽的名字。
但是很可惜
她的名字一直都沒有出現在名單上。
最後在1989年。
她是通過基因檢測。
真的找到了自己的親生母親。
但那個時候她已經去世了。
所以她們也沒有相見。
所以她媽媽也是姓存者。
對是姓存者
戰爭結束之後
她媽媽就一直在找她。
大概找了一年半都沒有任何消息。
所以她媽媽就以為土西亞已經死了。
因為那個時候屠殺的規模太大了。
所以她的媽媽就跟著猶太人一起去了以色列生活。
土西亞也說
她和楊母這種非常疏遠。
非常差的母女關係。
對她的性格影響非常大。
她為人非常冷漠
也不知道怎麼樣去表達自己的情感。
也不懂得如何向別人去表達愛意。
當然還有的孩子
寄養家庭的養父母對他們非常好。
事如己出
但是孩子們都是很敏感的。
他們總是能發現一些不太對勁的地方。
是的
那另外還有一個姓存的孩子。
就是你說的這種情況。
她是叫貝特卡
貝特卡她還是一個小嬰兒的時候就被帶出了隔督。
就是你之前不是講過。
他們會有幾種路線。
有的是裝在箱子裡。
有的是通過下水道去運送小孩出來。
那這個貝特卡呢？
她因為是一個小嬰兒。
所以她就是被裝在了小箱子裡面。
然後營救人員把這個箱子藏在了一堆磚塊裡。
就這樣給運出來的。
那她這麼小肯定是什麼都不記得。
是的
她被送出來之後呢？
就被送到了一個駐產市的家裡。
其實這個駐產市
也是一連大領導的地下組織的核心成員。
她和一連大的關係也是非常親近的。
那這位駐產市呢？
她是專門給奪起來的猶太女人接生的。
然後她會把新生兒安置到安全的寄養家庭裡面。
那這位駐產市
她自己是收養了貝特卡。
對她非常非常好
所以貝特卡從小就一直以為自己是媽媽的親生孩子。
她從來都沒有懷疑過什麼。
之前是說
每一個救出來的孩子都會有一個新身份。
那貝特卡她的新的出生證明上寫的是。
她是1942年出生的。
後面等到貝特卡14歲的時候。
她就跟著她的媽媽去給爸爸掃墓。
因為她小的時候
她媽媽就告訴她
父親已經去世了
然後去掃墓的時候。
她突然意識到
她爸爸的墓碑上寫的是。
1940年族
哦 時間不對
對
她就非常的疑惑
所以她就問
為什麼我爸爸在我出生之前就去世了。
那她媽媽給的解釋就是。
哦 是墓碑上的日期寫錯了。
那貝特卡也就沒有多想。
她就以為可能真的就是搞錯了。
就是她羊母也並不想告訴她她的真實身份。
是的
那後面有一天
他們生活的這個小鎮上來了幾個美國人。
他們在商店裡面買東西的時候。
就跟店老闆打聽
說你知不知道有貝特卡這個小孩。
當貝特卡的媽媽知道有人在找貝特卡的時候。
她突然變得非常的緊張。
她一直對貝特卡說。
沒事兒
媽媽和媽媽的朋友們都會保護你。
我覺得這個時候啊？
這個貝特卡的媽媽可能還處於那種暫時的印記狀態。
她一聽誰在找猶太兒童就會變得非常緊張。
三年之後
17歲的貝特卡她就是去了美國。
她在美國的一個怎麼紀念館裡面。
就突然看到了一份被營救的兒童名單。
她在那個上面找到了自己的名字。
她才發現
原來在她5歲的時候。
她的名字就出現在了這份名單上。
就是有相關的組織在這個時候已經找她了。
是的
她是17歲這個時候。
她才知道原來我不是媽媽的親生女兒。
原來父親墓碑上的日期沒有弄錯。
這個衝擊確實蠻大的。
那她後面有試圖去找過自己的親生父母嗎。
沒有
因為她知道她的養母非常在乎她。
她也能夠感受到這麼多年。
她的母親是在刻意的隱瞞她的身世。
所以她就不願意傷害她媽媽。
她覺得她要對她媽媽保持一種忠誠。
所以在這之後
她也就再也沒有提起過這件事。
不過後面等到貝特卡結了婚。
她有了自己的孩子。
自己成為母親之後。
她突然意識到
要讓一個母親把自己幾個月大的孩子就送走。
是多麼的殘忍
她突然一下子就非常心疼。
當時送走她的媽媽。
所以最後她還是去聯繫她的親生母親了。
對貝特卡來說確實是一個很難的決策。
確實
那除了剛剛我們講的這兩位。
還有很多的波蘭家庭。
她是被迫收養這些孩子的。
比如說這個波蘭家庭。
她最開始並不想收養猶太孩子。
但是人家只是說
你幫我照看這個孩子幾天。
過幾天我就把她接走。
你幫幫忙
但是後面就一直沒有人來。
所以這個孩子就這樣留在了他們家。
還有的家庭在二戰期間。
收養了猶太兒童
但是被反猶主義者給發現了。
他們會去舉報嘛？
然後就引來了很多的蓋士太保。
給他們家帶來了非常大的麻煩。
還有的家庭是
比如說媽媽統計收養。
爸爸不同意的
那你想這些孩子生活在這樣的家庭當中。
他就很難像正常的孩子那樣。
健康的成長
是的
很多幸存者都和貝特卡一樣。
很小很小就被送到了基養家庭裡面。
但是在成長的過程中。
他們就能明顯的感受到。
自己的父母對自己並不好。
就爸爸媽媽從來都不和自己親近。
有的甚至會打他們會羞辱他們。
所以他們就非常疑惑。
為什麼我媽媽爸爸不愛我呀？
是不是因為我沒有成為他們喜歡的樣子。
那還有的是
父母因為戰爭會出現一些心理疾病。
比如說遭遇症之類的。
他們的言行也會直接影響到這些孩子。
還有的孩子
雖然養父母對他們很好。
但是他發現
爸爸媽媽都是藍眼睛金頭髮。
而自己是黑眼睛棕頭髮。
根本不像是親生的呀？
但是他的家長就會對這件事情保持沉默。
對孩子來說
就好像家裡沒有一個祕密。
這個祕密還和自己有關。
但是所有人都必知不談。
他們就在這樣又好奇又害怕的環境當中慢慢長大。
還有的孩子本來生活得挺好的。
父母對他的保護也很好。
在八九歲的時候
家裡大聚餐
一個喝多了的叔叔突然露入他跟他說。
雖然你不是我們家的一份子。
但是我們都很愛你呀？
這小孩當時就懵了。
他自己嚇得娃娃大哭。
但是又不敢跟自己的媽媽爸爸去確認怎麼回事。
那還有那種家裡面的親戚朋友。
一些大的孩子就會知道他們是怎麼來的。
會嘲笑他們是爸爸媽媽撿來的小孩。
所以就有很多倖存者都說到。
因為父母的影響
他們的性格也會有很大的問題。
比如說他們也不會處理好人際關係。
他們的親死關係中也會存在各種各樣的問題。
你說的這個就是戰爭創傷的待機傳遞嘛？
就讓我想起來
咱倆前段時間去電影院看的那個電影情感價值。
對
電影當中那個爸爸他就是有一些情感缺陷。
是因為他媽媽當時是瑞典抵抗組織的成員。
被納粹抓了之後
遭受了非常嚴重的酷刑。
那他被放回來之後。
他受不了就在家裡面自殺了。
而這個男孩也就是影片當中的爸爸。
他成年之後也會有一些心理問題嘛？
最終也影響到了他和他妻子的夫妻關係。
以及他和他女兒的親子關係。
那事實上很多的戰爭創傷的研究都會說。
戰爭不是在簽投降書。
或是停戰的那一刻結束的。
他是會通過父母的情緒、思維。
以及家庭當中的那種沉默。
繼續進入下一代的生活。
是的 那我們今天所講的。
就只是整個這個事件的十分之一吧？
伊臉那是研究組織的核心人物之一。
除了他之外
還有很多他的戰友們的故事並沒有講。
之前提到的阿拉
他不是一直在葛都裡面救人。
最後被德軍抓貨帶到了集中營。
事實上他到了集中營之後。
還參與了一場猶太人的反抗行動。
他是在這次抵抗運動當中被納粹殺害的。
確實是戰鬥到了生命的最後一刻。
其實戰爭創傷的研究當中。
研究者就會發現
對創傷保持沉默是一種常見的處理方式。
就像是那個電影《情感價值》裡面。
那個父親的媽媽
他是瑞典地下抵抗組織的成員。
他曾經遭受過納粹的酷刑。
但是後面他回到自己家中之後。
對自己的遭遇都是閉口不談的。
所以他的孩子並不知道他經歷過了什麼。
伊聯娜也表現出了相同的態度。
當有研究者試圖讓他回憶當時的事件時。
他都說的很少很少。
他沒有透露自己在監獄裡面遭受過什麼。
關於亞當的事情
他也表現出來迴避的態度。
這可能也是他應對創傷的一種方式吧？
大家如果感興趣
可以通過收諾詞裡面的參考資料的鏈接。
去了解更多的信息。
是的
因為伊聯娜的這些人的事件。
也是近些年才被大家知道的。
那為什麼這件事情沉封了這麼久呢？
就是因為戰後波蘭他是進入了共產主義時期。
當時波蘭的領導人他是幾度的依賴蘇聯的。
那雖然伊聯娜他本人其實也是社會主義者。
但是波蘭當局是不允許公開傳播。
伊聯娜和他的朋友所做的這件事情的。
就相當於你開頭說的被封殺了。
因為二戰期間波蘭他是流亡政府。
伊聯娜是在流亡政府時期做的這些事情。
伊聯娜的營救組織裡面有社會工作者。
有天主教人員
有熱戈塔
等土軍
還和流亡政府有關。
實際上伊聯娜和他的組織是和戰後的新政權沒有關係的。
戰後波蘭的新政權掌管國家。
所以他就要確保自己政權的合法性。
新政權要宣揚的是蘇聯紅軍。
親社會主義的抵抗組織拯救了波蘭。
所以像伊聯娜這種不符合官方敘事體系的事情。
就會被壓制下來
那整個冷戰時期波蘭官方都不允許報到伊聯娜的世紀。
甚至當時以色列大屠殺紀念館給伊聯娜頒發了最高榮譽獎。
波蘭當局都不給他頒簽證。
不讓他去領獎
還用他的孩子來威脅他。
意思就是你不保持安靜的話。
就讓你的孩子上不了學。
沒有辦法生活
直到冷戰結束
一群美國高中生又重新發掘了這個故事。
再一次讓伊聯娜回到了大眾事業。
2008年98歲高齡的伊聯娜在華沙安翔理事。
結束了他偉大又燦爛的一生。
那本期的故事就講到這兒。
希望大家能夠喜歡。
我們在下一個故事裡等你。
拜拜
既然相遇始終來自於時光的窺藏。
那麼裏邊誓言一定要微笑著回憶放行中。
生命無限渺小卻同樣無限揮紅。
以為尋找或是告別。
後勁畢生也足夠讓人心動。
親愛的旅人你仍是記憶中的模樣。
穿過人群走過人間再去往更遠的遠方。
你靈魂深處總要有這樣一個地方。
永遠在海邊飄蕩在半空中飛揚。
永遠輕易永遠滾燙。
不願下塵埔坑下腳。
詞曲 李宗盛